the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the grand chess tour returns in glorious
fashion with the super bet chess classic
in Bucharest the game's best players are
ready to Dazzle the world from the
capital of Romania the first round
started off with sizzling games across
the boards but most simmered into
fighting draws however a draw was not
enough for American Wesley so who kicked
off the event by defeating reigning GCT
Champa lorenza farrugia in a come from
behind Victory the rust has been knocked
off and the world's best are ready to
shine day two of thrilling chess coming
up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
2023 Superbad chess Classic held in
Bucharest Romania we start the day in
front of the Romanian National Theater
an iconic Landmark here in the center of
Bucharest as we are waiting for the
players to arrive and start the battles
over the chessboard who is going to come
on top today let's go to the studio and
find out
we welcome you to the first step on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of superbed Romania we come to you live
from the Saint Louis chess club
hello and welcome everyone I'm
International Master Nazi paikide and
I'm here with one and only yester one
Naji I thought you were terrific your
first outing as a commentator and you
just nailed it yesterday oh thank you so
much it was great it was great you were
great hello everyone and Welcome to our
coverage of the grand chess tour we are
in round two and round one although
there weren't many results boy there was
a lot of really good hard Fighting Chess
something that we've really come to
expect from these illustrious Players
let's take a look at our standings Naji
after the first round right we already
have a leader in the tournament right
American Wesley so
who won a beautiful game yesterday
against alireza firucha the only player
to win impact right and the rest of the
field right now are sharing second
second place
and the format for our competition right
we have a 10 player around Robin with a
classical time control 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and 30 second increment
from move one
players are not allowed to offer any
draws and we have a regular regular
scoring system with one point for a win
half for a draw and zero for a loss and
our schedule for our opening event right
we have total of nine rounds and today
we'll start round two on Thursday May
11th the players will get a rest day and
after that they'll be back to finish
four rounds wonderful and we're very
fortunate to have in studio VAR
congratulations yourself the first day
you you had a great day uh broadcasting
as well good to see you in studio thank
you yes sir I'm very glad to be here it
was a lot of fun yesterday calling the
moves with you guys and we have some
very exciting games coming up today and
the leader Wesley so won an incredible
game yesterday with the black pieces
against firusha
let's take a look at the winners of the
grand Chester 2015 Magnus Carlson won
2016 Wesley so 2017 Magnus Carlson again
2018 Hikaru Nakamura 2019 dingler in and
2021 Wesley Seoul and last year of
course alireza Phil Roosevelt
in last year's winner of this tournament
was nvl and the really good chance and
dominated this event
let's take a look at a head-to-head he's
facing Wesley so today and look at the
stats six wins only one last and 20
draws probably the only player in the
world who has such a dominating score
against Wesley saw
and we're gonna go to Romania to our
friend Grandmaster Christian chirilla
thanks VAR and welcome chess fans for a
day two here in Bucharest Romania at the
2023 super bad chess classic and what an
explosive first day of Chess we had
yesterday that game in particular
between Fabiano caruana and The Prodigy
the Romanian Prodigy Daniel only 21
years of age and he's already a super
Grand Master
2700 that one was an intriguing battle I
have to say Fabiano brought in an
explosive opening uh preparation with
that Rook to C1 and F3 no Castle on the
board but it was just simply not enough
to take the full point home Bogdan
Daniel dag I have to say defend it quite
well in that one and there is one Jan
Gustafson here in Bucharest as well he's
uh probably seconding Anish giri and he
did mention that if you try too hard
against Wesley so to get an advantage
with the white pieces you will get
punished and that's exactly what
happened with
got a tense position out of the opening
maybe a slight Advantage with the white
pieces but after that slowly slowly he
got himself in time travel situation and
Wesley saw was just clinical and
extremely precise to take home the full
point and become the early leader in at
the event the atmosphere here in
Bucharest is just simply electrifying
the fans already we are ready as
commentators and I'm sure the players
are ready to start day two action as
well back to you guys in St Louis thank
you Christian looks like a nice crowd
everybody's ready and as we get ready
for round two lay the table for viewers
and tell them what they can expect in
terms of pairings right let's take a
look we have exciting matchups on board
one we have Maxi Michelle agraph playing
our tournament leader Wesley so that's
got to be our Marquee matchup right
there MBL with plus six and only one
loss to Wesley so that's remarkable
please continue I'm Anish Gary against
ferrugia rapid against Duda nice diac
versus nipomishi and our champion ding
against Fabiano caruana that's another
very very nice uh Mark Heights Marquee
matchup indeed as we get a view with the
players that are getting all set I just
want to talk for a moment about the
drawing of lots because clearly with
nine rounds some players are going to
get five blacks or five whites when the
sinkhill come cup comes around then
they'll switch so that they will balance
out I also want to say that for Wesley
so what a terrible start because he's
get he gets black against the number one
seed then he gets black against the guy
who's who's beating him like a drum I
mean what a he's doing great so far yeah
he's doing great and he's in first place
so I mean if he gets through today's
Challenge and it is a challenge when
somebody really has your number and you
don't feel comfortable again player then
bad things happen but if he gets through
today's challenge watch out Wesley so
could be very formidable
in any case uh that lots of Hard fights
what are they fighting for they're
fighting for a lot of money there's a
total price fund of 350 000 and the
first place winner is going to get one
hundred thousand dollars second place 65
000 third place forty eight thousand as
you said very handsome price fund all
the way down to 10th Place ten thousand
dollars lots of grand chest tour points
up for grabs you win clear first you get
a bonus of an extra GCT point of 13. tie
for first and you start splitting the
points uh the player who has the most
GCT points at the end of the tour gets
an additional one hundred thousand
dollar bonus as we're getting ready for
some oh you know opening ceremonial
first moves we've got some real celebs
making these moves and we're expecting
do you know
good guess
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
flowers who is the CEO and chairman of
JC flowers or whether it's Hank who is
actually the executive uh Chief
Operating Officer of First Bank so take
your pick is it J flowers or Hank not
sure
he will be making the opening ceremonial
moon for Daniel the world champion
and it's sort of like ding
74 again right
there you have it
very nice
and being took to move back
because it's still uh these days
a personal for Richard Pennsylvania
typically Richard H3 yeah
what F3 Knight F3 Knight F3 I don't
think Gary was very happy with Knight F3
right very conservative yes flexible
foreign
[Applause]
sponsor here for the tournament will
make a first move at the third table to
make
and the president of the executive
committee a member of the board of
directors Maybe
and this is Hank executive Chief
Operating Officer for first part
[Applause]
foreign
she is the operating partner for JC
flowers and Company elinka
well you're supposed to say Well done
yet so you did that really you did a
great job thank you that's all I wanted
to do and look at
proudly played
[Applause]
[Music]
I lost a live audience yes
so many people are so excited to watch
and two Nations that no longer exist
Soviet Union and Yugoslavia when you
played in the playing Hall oftentimes it
was standing room only like to stop
standing room only and the crowds
they knew when the bullet Boy made the
wrong move they would be whistling and
booing it was it was great stuff I mean
the very very knowledgeable uh chess
players uh oh this one is new on me I I
had I had three not four
actually this is what I always like is
women
he was the first to do so but I always
liked that when they come
today
for an important round which is today
and if the rest the microphone
audience yeah
I know that in Bucharest they also have
commentary rooms and places where people
can go and talk about the game so this
is just a section of the audience it's
not you know the entire audience and
there's a media center uh journalist
room and those journalists or
enthusiastic fans as well
players are excited to make the first
move VAR do you feel uh nervous at these
moments when everybody keeps talking
talking talking you want the armor to
come and start the clocks yeah a little
bit sometimes especially if it's like a
really important tournament and you kind
of want to get get going and start
playing chess exactly
exactly uh heavy heavyweight match up
here new world champion dingler in
facing
Bobby
and he will want to take advantage of
his second wide pieces exactly
didn't get actually he got surprised
yesterday yeah against them against MVM
play Queen's Gambit accept it and they
had a pretty easy time
yeah Greenfield was expected right
now Duda is just one of those players
who has great promise great potential
but we've been saying that for several
years already VAR but he hasn't made
that breakthrough to what we might call
the 2800 Club yes I agree he is
incredibly strong player he had a really
really strong World Cup in 2021 in in
Russia yeah to impress a lot of people
there
um he's still he's still I think getting
there and I think he's he's almost there
to make a big breakthrough
all right as the games are underway I'm
just going through uh the various
Richard did ended up actually playing
Knight F3 on move one and he kept it by
the way yeah I didn't uh bring him back
uh you might have seen Gary's reaction
since Knight F3 was like no the problem
was because his long time Scourge and
rival Vladimir kramnik was playing this
strategic opening move Knight F3 so he
Gary had to play Knight F3 the move of
kramnik and I was like you know give me
a chance to play E4 understandable but I
am a fan of Knight F3 right you're not
letting your opponent know yet exactly
what your plans are I think it's an
extra an excellent first move as well of
course uh D4 Knight F6 Wesley
doubtlessly
London system uh Bishop F4 not even
Bishop G5 wow Bishop F4 I think after
ding won a game or two at the world
championship match with the London yeah
it this opening will be more popular now
than ever before or anything that's a
great segue into for yuvar what is going
on with the London we know about this
opening for a hundred years already and
suddenly you know in the 23rd Century it
becomes popular the London opening y
well it's very interesting because it's
uh especially like ding playing this in
a world championship level and proving
that you know he can get good positions
he won that one game with the white
pieces in a you know to equalize the
match so it's it's still playable you're
not gonna get that much Advantage but uh
you'll be able to get some playable
positions and likely avoid the Deep
preparation of your opponent but there
is another game that caught my eye is
the game Anish giri he played The slav
Exchange
against firuja
and we don't see the exchange variation
that often anymore yeah yeah we don't
see it too often here and I I kind of um
I like this opening because I've been
playing it for a very long time right
and uh this particular line is very
interesting I can show some moves sure
so so yeah he played Knight C3 here
again blackhead option here to take on
C4 but then you have the move E4 here
for example we can play A4 as well but
he played Knight F6 and now we have the
exchange radiation and it starts with
the move Bishop F4 and uh there there
are some differences here if you start
with Knight F3 uh then Knight F3 there
is Knight C6 for example but he wants to
play for this early Queen B3 idea that's
why he played the move Bishop F4 and now
we have Knight C6
E3 and the move Queen B3 here instead of
playing the normal Knight F3 the point
is now you're attacking on B7 and uh
black black really needs to play this
move Knight A5 in this position if you
play Queen B6 this end game is
considered slightly worse
after Knight F3 the pawns are just weak
on B6 and B B7 if you play
um if you try to defend like you never
really want to play the move B6 in this
position because then after Bishop
Bishop B5 is going to be a really nice
Advantage here B6 you want to always
avoid in this in this positions and if
you play the move for example Queen B3 a
queen D7 then there is Knight F3 you
have to be really careful there are a
lot of traps here like for example E6
now this is a big problem 95 attacking
the queen if you capture and here you
will take back with the pawn attacking
the Knight and as soon as the Knight
moves Bishop B5 of course we're not
We're not gonna see anything like this
happening in this game but there are a
lot of tricks in this position
one of my favorite traps you just showed
and here we have a lifetime scores we
need more database uh only two games two
classical games yeah it's a little
strange I haven't played so many games
against each other right well again
purusha even though he's a tall guy he's
actually really really young and it's
only in the last two three years that
he's exploded into onto the chess scene
so he he hasn't really that many games
against these top top guys but he
belongs uh with the top guys by the way
a lot more moves have been played uh go
ahead and take us to the current
position bar and tell us what the
theoretical outcome is of the game of
the position they have on their board
yes let's let's catch up on the moves
here and uh let's take a look here so we
play Queen B3 and Knight A5 is
essentially forced in this position
which was played attacking the queen but
now Queen a4j the point of this move is
now you're forcing the bishop to go back
on D7 and then black will play six and
the bishop will be blockaded on D7 so
Queen C2 and E6 and now the bishop is
not as active on D7 but you do lose
couple of tempos with this queen B3
Queen A4 Queen C2 I've actually played
like this a few times I had a game
against Grandmaster fresenet from France
so it's it's it's it's very tricky white
sometimes can get an advantage here
Bishop D3 Rook C8
Knight F3 Bishop B4
now putting pressure on C3 and he went
to Castle so this is very important now
and a lot of times you wouldn't play the
move 95 here right so as far as Theory
um we're about 150 games I can see in
this position and um
black can play castle here another
option is for example Knight H5 to try
to attack this bishop in this case white
has an option to play Bishop E5 or for
example can also play the move Bishop G5
here so it's uh but it's important to
see now for which of which line alireza
will go for but again two top moves are
here castle and Knight H5 there are some
games play with the move Knight C4 as
well in this position if you play Knight
C4 then uh
the bishop C4 is important just to
eliminate if you take with the Knight
with a rook then you're allowing the
move Knight E5 putting pressure on the
rook and again you still need to Castle
so probably Knight C4 it's now would be
my Top Choice in this position but there
are games as you can see chromic against
aronian head disposition so it's it's
possible that we'll see this so still no
moves after Castle here so uh we'll see
how firusha will continue here thank you
back to you guys lucky to have an expert
in this
looking for us I know it's great right
the amazing what you can learn just by
watching our program uh I want to say
Naji we have a theme in round two white
is putting his Bishop on F4 wow and not
one not two but three of the games
in all different ways we're getting a
Queen's Gambit decline with the bishop
on F4 slob defense with the bishop on F4
and then the most direct of them all
London you know with the vision F4 uh
let's run through some of these games
I've got the game up on my screen of
nepo
and we will remember this from the 2018
World Championship match between Magnus
Carlson and Fabiano where Magnus was
putting his Bishop on F4 uh is far more
traditional in the Queen's Gambit
decline to have the bishop on G5 but the
bishop on F4 has its own nuances and you
can enter some very very sharp concrete
lines
Bishop F4 we sell long Castle more often
from the white side right yeah we do
like if black doesn't go maybe
immediately C5 right you could play for
example some move like B6 and uh or even
without taking without Queen C2 and long
castle and H4 and so on let's have some
fun I mean it's not our position we got
the Kings on opposite flanks and like I
say those kinds of games uh lead to you
know really double-edged stuff but C7 C5
has long been considered the optimal way
right of equalizing against the move
Bishop F4 and why is that when the
bishop is on G5 the move C5 is frowned
upon because after D4 takes C5 the
natural recapture would leave the knight
in a pin so when the bishop goes to G5
the early C5 is rejected but with the
bishopon F4 C5 takes takes
um
and it's funny I just cited the World
Chess Championship match of 2018 but
this position I could cite the
um world championship match of 1978
Baguio City between Victor korginoi and
Anatoly karpov with Queen C2
castles long Knight D2 and they got some
really really ferocious games going on
there and I might just jump in with VAR
and ask him you can also see dick at the
board trying to remember the lines or
deciding which line to play He seems
surprised by this opening choice right
pineapple
I don't think Nepal placed this very
often
uh this particular line
yeah yeah yeah I mean again I've always
associated nepo with the grunefell but
as he started winning world
candidates tournament you could see that
the repertoire became you know Russian
defense and you know like super super
solid
um this current position that dayak is
studying uh what's uh what are the
vagaries of theory today what are the
modern ideas are yeah let's take a look
there's some major major Theory here
Yasser I see about 3 000 games played in
this position and then let's take a look
some of the moves here and looks like
Jack is pausing a little bit trying to
decide what to do A3 is one of the top
moves here uh played over 1 000 games in
this position another option here is to
play Queen C2 as you mentioned with idea
to play long Castle but also sometimes
you play the move Rook D1 in this
position as well so like let's say
Knight C6
and here again you have many different
options A3 is the main move oftentimes
you want to play this move A3 in order
to control the B4 Square so you don't
have to deal with the move Knight before
another option here could be the move
Rook D1 here as well
um I've played this position so as black
and as white as well it's it's not easy
to to navigate through the complications
sometimes there's so many different
lines to go to but definitely a lot of
theory and looks like nepo is prepared
to play this line but another game
actually caught my eye I wanted to show
you is the game report versus uh Duda
here so from move number two actually we
see so it started off with Knight F3 uh
D5 G3 and now Knight D7
uh the first time I think this was
played by Alex cienko in a grand Swiss
tournament in 2019 one of the top
players who played this move 97 and the
idea just he wants to play E5 here if if
you're allowed let's say you play Bishop
G2 then black can play the move E5 ish
so black will try white will try to
prevent that so he played the move d4
but then Knight comes would be six in
this position to prevent the C formal
which is the the main idea in this
positions for why to try to attack on
the queen side here and put some
pressure on D5 and now uh Knight C3 was
played uh might be a little bit
counter-intuitive to putting the Knight
here but uh to blockade the C4 but it's
going to be hard to do it with a knight
on B6 at the moment so and also perhaps
white wants to play the move E4 and
again there's only a few moves played in
this position there is a game of with
Ali Reza playing against voitashek from
2021 and few other games between a grand
master so now Bishop F5 is played and
now another interesting move Knight H4
so these players are differently
avoiding all the theoretical lines and
now playing a very interesting game now
the bishop is now under attack on F5 and
black needs to make a decision where to
put this bishop and we have to do that
thinking here and he's already spent
about seven minutes not an easy position
to play you have Bishop G4 option uh if
you go Bishop G6 I think after Knight
takes G6 wipe will be slightly better so
definitely interesting uh game here and
he just played the move E6 so he's
actually giving up the bishop here and I
think white is going to have a slightly
better position here I think once you
get this bishop yeah so I think white
should be better here so back to you
guys yeah very creative approach by play
by both players but let's jump to
Bucharest as Christian as one of our
sponsors
thank you Yasser yes we are here with
the CEO of First Bank Hank party Cooper
Hank first of all welcome uh to the show
tell us a bit about this new partnership
between First Bank and the grandchester
and super batches classes yes thank you
thank you well I mean we this is the
second year that first bank is um
sponsoring this the grandias tour and
we're very pleased with this
we we would like to to continue and we
see a lot of similarities between
business between banking actually and
and between yeah so we feel perfectly at
ease what is this what would you say
those main attributes are the
transferable ones between chess and
business in your opinion yes of course
well first of all you need to have a
strategy you need to have a plan in
business and also with jazz and you need
to take action you need to do something
then of course your opponent is also
acting so you need to adapt you need to
be flexible you need to understand how
to react to the movements of of your
opponent and in chess and in business
it's it's the same you need to be able
to sacrifice you need to invest
sometimes you need to give up something
in order to gain something something
else and of course the last thing but
certainly not the the least important
maybe the most important you want to win
and you want to win the game and you
want to win in business as well a lot of
similarities speaking of investment time
management is also something that you
invest whenever you think about a
specific move in chess does that apply
to business as well another one it's a
very valid one there is always the the
pressure of time time is money time is
scar so that you also need to take into
consideration yeah Hank thank you very
much for joining us now before I let you
go uh we have the world champion here we
have so many illustrious chess players
who is your favorite to win this yes
well first of I would like to say that
in First Bank we did a tournament
ourselves and the winner of uh the First
Bank tournament was given a seat at the
table on Friday at the simultaneous
and our employee uh was actually the
only winner in the simultaneous so he
beat Mr casparov and he beat all the the
chess players it's a difficult question
so there is some Mr uh report from from
Romania and there is also a Romanian
bank but there is also Mr Anish giri and
his Dutch anniversary from the
Netherlands so I'm not yet sure who of
the two but I would say the two of them
are my favorites Anish and Richie
definitely solid picks correct Hank
thank you very much for joining thank
you so much
thank you Hank and uh thank you
Christian I just like to jump right into
the Catalan as a nice game going on
between dingler in and Fabiano I was
happy to see Catalan yes exactly and uh
it's one of those Perpetual favorites it
always has uh it always comes back at
waxes and wanes and I'm very curious
about the move D5 takes C4 in what we
call the open Catalan of course black
can play what we call the closed Catalan
moves like C6 B6 Bishop B7 and so on
but when you play the open Catalan D5
takes C4
I found in my experience it's nice to
have White's Bishop on the D2 Square
so that including Bishop before check
exactly but look what ding did he didn't
allow he didn't push his teeth on so he
didn't allow the bishop B4 check these
guys
yes and now after detox Queen C2 there's
no there's there hasn't been that
swishin Zug of Bishop before Jack Bishop
D2 Bishop back to E7 so the bishop has
retained its original position on C1 now
A7 A6 uh by far the most
common move that was played in the 70s
and 80s in this position was the move
Queen takes C4 B5 Queen C2 and thousands
of games went from this very specific
position I think there is um
in that line with Bishop B7 and white
develops the black Square bishop and
there's like Bishop E4 Queen Sivan
Bishop goes back and repeat right right
exactly so there's a lot of drugs in the
database with this uh right yeah exactly
and it excuse me don't ask me for all
the subtleties as to why this does end
up in a uh repetition but yes there
there are those long games now in this
particular case what ding did is he
stopped the move B5 he played A4
and with the move A4 you slightly
weakened your control over the B4 square
and after the move Knight C6 uh the idea
is that black ends up establishing his
Knight on before you think to yourself
well is that so why is that so
impressive it in all of these Catalan
positions
it comes down to a very very easy
question
how are you going to neutralize the
bishop on G2
if you don't
you have a bad game's going to be
precisely exactly but if you can put
your knight on B4 so let me just make a
move and not necessarily a good move
right I just put some moves on the board
like this
and the bishop could come here or you
could play B5 but before I get too deep
uh let's go back to Bucharest and
Christian with another guest
thank you VAR we are here with uh Chris
flower CEO and managing director of JC
flowers and Company Chris first of all
welcome to the show Welcome uh to
Bucharest what are your first
impressions of this tournament so far
what a show you know how fantastic how
glamorous it's great to be here you're
an avid chess player yourself as well
you've played some of the greatest chess
players on the planet in fact tell us
about your Beginnings in the Chess World
how did you discover chess oh I've been
playing chess all my life I should be
better than I am I have a lot of
explaining to do what would you say are
some of the attributes that you've taken
from your chess experience and apply
them to the business world
discipline foresight time management I
wish I could do all those better
now in 2015 you also joined the board of
directors of the Casper of Chess
Foundation now the Casper of Chess
Foundation finds discovers and nurtures
the best talents in the world how proud
are you very proud indeed in the cast
broadcast Foundation does fantastic work
for chess and in general for kids and
for the world now final question tell us
a bit about this tournament once again
we have dingly run the newly crowned
world champion what is your estimation
of his powers you know I was thinking
about this I wish they could all win you
have such fantastic chess players out
there you know uh and and they're
they're all tremendous so
um
very hard to pick and I have to say uh
I've seen you play in the same team with
Fabiano caruana in London a few years uh
back how did that partnership uh go did
you help him uh succeed he he did great
and and mostly because of you I have to
say I don't think I added much to it he
wasn't too interested in my ideas Chris
always a pleasure to have you on the
show thank you very much for joining us
AQ Christian I apologies everybody I
just having a bit of a cold nursing
situation Knight C6 uh I was about to
say in the game of thing Lauren and Fabi
and uh Fabi wants to play Knight C4 and
he wants to play B5
so I was trying to just put a move on
the board for a second say Rook D1 and I
wanted to put this and to to just show
uh oops a very very nasty trap do not
think that you could capture on B5 if
the queen moves let's just I'll put it
backwards then you can
from B4 can always jump to D5 precisely
that's exactly right actually the Knight
will be very pleased on uh the D5 Square
envar what caught your attention and
very promising uh round two the openings
have been great quite a variety too
absolutely yeah sir this this moment of
this game actually you've been analyzing
against Carolina and there is a reason
why ding is spending a lot of time here
because Knight C6 is not the main move
in this position the main move is the
move Bishop D7 here with the idea to
play Bishop C6 and ibd7 but Knight C6
has been played about about 300 almost
300 games now and it's very direct idea
putting pressure on D4 and here the main
move is actually just to take the pawn
immediately with Queen takes C4 and then
black has some options here Queen D5 is
the main move try to exchange the queens
and then you have the option of to play
let's say an ibd2 Rook d8 again putting
pressure you really want to force the
trade here and then you can take back
with the pawn as well opening up the
diagonal for the bishop so again white
doesn't want to trade so can play the
move E3 and uh there there there's still
uh some games played in this position
and uh here black can take perhaps
Knight C4 and play Bishop D7 uh very
very solid position for black uh but I
think definitely a surprise here and
that's why he's he's been he's been
thinking in this position so Queen C4
actually played looks like and Fabiano
immediately played the move Knight A5
and uh another rare move only 17
um games played in this position and the
idea is to attack the queen and you know
probably try to play C5 immediately so
let's say queen C2 and uh
maybe you can even just go back Knight
C6 to put pressure on the pawn on D4 and
uh maybe even put the Knight on before
after that with the tempo so that is
that is one idea for this game uh I want
to go back to the report game against
and we saw the move E6 played and my
first impression is this is probably
going to be slightly better for White
Queen D3 now played after capturing on a
five attack in the pawn on F5 now
forcing the move G6
and now Bishop G2 if somehow y can open
up the center maybe at some point even
F3 E4 quickly played he should have some
Advantage Here and Now Knight F6 is
played it's not so easy because black
has a lot of control on the uh E4 square
but uh still because of the two Bishops
I think white is has a slightly better
position what an interesting back to you
guys thank you thank you yeah what an
interesting Pawn structure and black
exchange The White Square Bishop early
right but now it's compensating it with
the pawns put in almost every Pawn on
the white squares exactly I
I think uh I fell under a little bit uh
the influence of Michael bobinick who
played the Dutch defense which is
horrible of course we know it's horrible
but okay and you know the problem with
the Dutch defense was besides creating
all of these weaknesses especially on
the E5 Square
the light squared Bishop but the Dutch
defends
is so wonderful when you don't have a
light squared picture problem and it
reminds me a little bit of the stone
wall with the pawns on D5 and F5 with
the eliminated uh light Square Bishop I
don't have to worry about Knight E5 and
even though I might be sympathetic to
widen the two Bishops I really kind of
feel like
black has an easy game like if you just
let him play Bishop G7 castles rookie 8
and 94
what do you got but everything can
change very quickly if white manages to
play F3 for at some point right let me
just bring that uh game up on the board
because again it was very creative
almost from a move too like what 1937
and right here yes this is it and you
were about to tell us in the future
castles Bishop G7 yes right if white
manages to successfully push E4 right
and change the pawn structure right then
white will have an advantage because of
the pair of Bishops yes exactly now it's
going to be actually not that simple to
execute this so for example after F3 I
Castle now as you've just described it
the very desirable move is to play E4
but you may regret the fact that this
bishop is you know in Ambush it's rather
lurking we have to protect D4 first
precisely if there was no Queen mean
takes D4 then everybody can understand
exactly what you're talking about which
is this flowering visual log diagonal
yeah which defends the King on on a G1
but it's a Catalan Bishop right that's
the Catalan Bishop so it's going to take
a little bit more work than you know you
don't just get to play E4 you gotta you
gotta do
preparation if you will because why it
also has slightly awkward development on
the Twin Side exactly Knight on C3
exactly it would be actually ironic in
this exact position if white decided
that he would like to put his Rook on D1
he'd move his Bishop to F4 then four out
of the five games would be featuring the
bishop on F4 uh whoa he just played
Bishop G5 I think
the board maybe to prepare long castles
or so I wanted to jump to the game of
Napa for a moment but I need your help
bar on this one
so
uh in particular if you have on your
database a game between
Jonathan Spillman is white and Nigel
short from a candidates let's take a
look
um I know one thing Yasser H6 was a very
rare move I've been told uh in this
position and I just checked as well in
this position there's lots of games
played Black mostly plays Bishop E7 here
um or rookie 8 or Rook d8 but this H6 is
a very rare So a Spielman game in this
position in this exact position yeah
from the opening uh let's go back maybe
a few moves
does it pop up no it doesn't it doesn't
pop out I have all the the most popular
moves the way this database is set up
here yeah but this H6 move it's it's
definitely like a new new idea and uh
now after the move Rook D1 I would have
seen Knight D2 instead of Bishop E2 what
would have been the most popular
response right it's actually not so many
games played in this position because of
the the rare move H6 I see only eight uh
games in my database here Bishop E2 is
one option Bishop D3 and also the move
you mentioned 92 as well it's it's a
typical move in this position so we see
it often with idea to play Knight B3 and
also sometimes for the Knight is only
two you actually are ready to play the
move before because if you play the
before immediately I think there is a
night before and this pin is going to be
very very strong here and you have the
94 coming up as well so
so but he played
Bishop E2 and now Knight E4 played and
here's uh it's possible we're gonna see
uh some end game here after yeah I think
we have some moves she takes D5
I played he takes D5 it's very
interesting and now Rook D5 played right
and now any games in the database no
actually I don't have any games in my
database at least uh so the last move is
uh
yeah Knight takes C3 and this is yeah
this is uh
the move was Knight C3 the last game I
have in my database so e takes D5 seems
like a novelty here by nepo ah
interesting thank you um yeah
um let's take a look at it ourselves so
hey guess what my favorite living
condition I'm a pawn up rook takes D5
um
oh right uh
this one is a very very tough question
for me but let me imagine that I would
play C3 takes D5
now I don't know it looked like maybe we
transposed back into
um regular channels suddenly so Black's
going to take on A3 Queen A3 let's
imagine Queen takes A3 castles and
Bishop E6 probably naturally now this is
this is the crucial moment right here
right now now most of the time you're
very happy to keep your Rook centralized
it's just that you don't always get this
opportunity to go a little bit crazy you
know and I I like crazy oh wow yeah I'm
expecting that exactly uh very
unexpected Rook H5 you don't see this
because often because usually there's a
night on F6 so you don't get the chance
to do this but you are telegraphing
a very clear punch you're ready to go
Bishop takes H6 you're ready to go Queen
H7 and you're ready funnily enough to
play the move Knight G5 Black's Queen is
so far away from the King exactly cannot
help defend and so is the Knight on C6
so maybe this can actually be dangerous
precisely and you know there's a very
nice looking trap in the position the
move Bishop G4 at first bellage you see
that move and you go oh my gosh my Rooks
uh horrible until you see the move
Knight G5 and then you go oh oh look at
this guess who's having a lot of fun
suddenly uh you can't take the Rook as a
mate on H7 you can't take the Knight
decimate on H7 and the G4 Bishop
obviously Bishop G4 is hanging so that
was what caught my eye and why I thought
yeah you know I'd like to keep Queens on
the board now having said everything I
just said Queen takes C3 Queen takes c3b
takes E3 Bishop takes A3
hard for me to imagine that white is
significantly better in this end game I
don't I think uh pawns on A7 and B7 can
be quite dangerous once they start to
advance precisely actually guys there is
a very interesting move here if you play
Queen takes C3 in that vibration uh if
you they're a black has the small Bishop
before oh wow okay and uh black is
winning the exchange it's not so clear
actually white still has a good
compensation but it's just really nice
move so if you take on A5 then just
Bishop takes you three check and here
black will be clearly better up exchange
but you do have the move a takes before
and now Queen takes D5 and actually B5
and white has a compensation here
because wow Knight doesn't have any good
scores to go to has to retreat on E7 and
now after Castle we also have this great
Square for the Knight to go to on D4
then we go Bishop F3 and uh it's a it's
it's the engine is showing all zeros in
this position
first of all let me be very clear I
blundered The Exchange good morning St
Louis you know like blundered the
exchange but then as you were talking
VAR and showing this compensation nice
squares Rook D1 two Bishops two Bishops
I mean it wasn't the worst blunder I've
ever made uh I was gonna say I do think
uh Yasser he's white should take with
the pawn on C3 though and the line you
guys were showing is absolutely uh
correct here you have to play the move
Rook H5 here okay in this position and
after you take on A3 just castle and uh
there are some threads here and actually
looks like black needs to play very
precisely here and you have to play the
move Knight E7 here very very important
move because of this threat you
mentioned Knight G5 is very strong here
so you have to play either you have to
play the move F5 but it looks a little
bit weakening the position but your best
move is 97 and then why test few options
to play Bishop D3 is one option another
option is to play for example Knight D4
Knight D4 uh
Bishop takes on D4 C takes D4 and
95 is you know it's it's it's still very
complicated here but uh this Rook on H5
is uh it's very interesting it's still
got some threads and Bishop page six you
always have to watch out for sighting B
Tech C3 is critical but we see deck is
thinking right now he's trying to figure
out uh which way to capture here with
the queen or the pawn thank you for uh
some messy stuff going on there
um I I just want to say that we really
enjoy your challenging uh questions and
there's a way for you to join the
discussion uh kind of push us into
directions that you might like us to go
by asking the commentators right
there is do we know who's Anastasia
Anastasia is managing our social media
yes yes and there you have it at uh
hashtag you can send us tweets at
hashtag super bad chess classic exactly
um jumping to the game of fobby and
dingler and I had this absolutely
marvelous recollection of a game I had
once played against Nigel short from the
London Phillips and Drew a different
time uh the night on C6 right is like a
dream a night it's a very very powerful
night but black wants to play Knight d8
and kick it out I was just gonna say
what do you think about the name B7 it's
an awful night but it's terrible very
temporary exactly once again expel of
the night let's see how the players got
there because one of the things we were
talking about in this Catalan is if
black neutralizes the bishop EA or nay
if the answer is no I'm gonna like white
very much let's see how Fabi did it
Queen takes C4 after Queen takes C4
Knight F5 we're mostly discussed tonight
before but as well as I think the
traditional move here is Queen D5 just
kind of gaining that Tempo against the
queen and as varusian was mentioning any
Queen trades really are very helpful to
the second player because now this Pawn
um blocks the diagonal while
simultaneously opening up opening up the
diagonal for the bishop so the move
that's a bit of surprises 85 Queen C2
ready so looking at fabriano's clock he
has one hour 33 minutes so this is all
prep absolutely Knight E5 and you know
you kind of stop at a certain moment as
a chess player uh and just go I love it
you just say you know like I you know
you you see this position with the
Knight on C6 and you know I you know
sign me up you know let's go for that
and because as you said
Fabi is playing so quickly it's a clear
giveaway right he's had this position on
the board he's looked deeper than just
the shallow your knight is on C6 it's
going to get booted Rook D1 Rooks he ate
and we caught up with the players he's
definitely prepared to exchange that
night very quickly otherwise this would
not be a good line no no the Knight on
B7 is a pathetic looking creature but
once you play Knight d8 so if we were to
continue like uh in a dream world
somehow this night would be reinforced
right I mean but we're we're Tempe
behind and we can't do it so right if I
put the Knight on C3 it's not like it
hangs at 96 good morning sunlight good
morning St Louis thank you that clears
the cobweb so and we maybe play E4 and
D5 let's do it let's give it a shot E4
Knight D5 that pardon me 98. you can
take on E7 also and okay Bishop G5
that's also interesting right so we play
against the two knights the only thing
is I think well you have the central
Palm Duo pardon me please one is
slightly behind in development on the
queen side I would have loved to have
night on C3 right now true then I would
have a big Advantage exactly but here
black might have C5 very quickly and um
yeah the other thing that I in this
specific position that black might have
is an option you know one of the things
that I do no not one of the things I do
do this is I constantly ask my guys how
you doing you happy you happy you happy
well I know one guy who's really really
unhappy is the night on d8 and so when I
play the move E5 the Knight on d8 says
thank you yes that's really nice of you
because on a good game I played D5 now
right
uh D5 now I like this idea what you were
about to propose was which was to break
open the queen side you wanted to play
C5 a moment ago which I like but I
wanted uh if you go I feel that this is
more of a liability than an asset right
I think I've lost very quickly exactly
um but we do have a move in the game
what do we have I think played Bishop G5
right away loud without E4
um that's a bit of a surprise what's his
idea softer night if black still plays
Knight d8 98 I'm assuming he wants to
take the bishop right he may be
transpose into similar transpositional
everybody first
instead of E4 I mean you mean here
well I must say my my Spidey Sense isn't
tingling I don't feel the danger you
tell me if you think that white has
something uh significant here uh Farah
jump in on this conversation uh the move
Bishop G5
feels a little Tad wrong
uh it's an interesting move there is one
idea in particular that I like I do like
also the move 92 you guys were
mentioning earlier so let's take a look
at both so in this position he played
the move Bishop G5 Knight D2 is actually
very nice too because with the idea
Knight F3 now to go to E5 and if you
play the move 90 which you really have
to you cannot you have to remove the
knight from C6 here so if you're playing
Knight d8 the idea is now you just take
only seven and if you take back and now
you play this move B3 I really like this
move now and now Bishop is coming to A3
and it's going to make it more difficult
to play the move C5 so this is actually
a clear Advantage for white here because
if you play the move C5 now then Bishop
A3 and now you're you're pinned if you
play something like Knight B7 then after
Knight C4 it's a it's a clear Advantage
here for white so so I really like the
move 92 but he went he went for the move
Bishop G5 so if you play the move and
Fabi looks like I already played the
move h six in this which is the best
move here if you play the move Knight d8
white white can obtain an advantage
after Knight takes E7 Queen takes E7 and
now a very interesting move here Bishop
F6 is also slightly better but I like
this move Rook A3 oh
and the point is you actually want to
bring the Rook you also have some ideas
Rook F3 now and try to take on F6 and if
C5 is played but the main idea is after
C5 you just take on F6
Queen takes F6 and now you can play Rook
C3 that's awkward and now now The Rook
is pinned on C8 and if let's say you
play an IBC
trying to bring now D takes
C5 you cannot take back again with the
Knight because of the move before
so it's just a very very awkward
position here and if you take with the
Rook on C5 Rook takes C5
um
Rook takes C5 and if you take with the
pawn it's always really bad with the
Knight on B7 you have Rook D7 move here
so in uh I think white is a little bit
better here in this lines here is
actually much better so that's why H6 is
very important immediately to question
the bishop on G5 now now a dink has to
make a decision and the way that Fabi is
playing he's got still one hour and 33
minutes I think wow he's still in prep
guys yeah absolutely that's a dead
giveaway as we get uh p uh prepared for
a first break I always think that we
have to pay respects so whoever's
leading the tournament that's it you
know you can't go on break without
talking about the guy or gal who's in
first place and in this case we kind of
lost sight about in the game between mvl
and uh let's say so it was a London
system and uh Wesley said okay you put
your Bishop on F4 I'll grab the center
with the move C5 and
I'm gonna go uh hunting uh dark Square
Bishop what are you gonna do now Bishop
G3 well you kind of tepidly allow me uh
to
um
fulfill my plan so mvl said no no no
yeah I'm going to make you work for it
if you want to play the mo if you want
to go G5 I've got Knight takes G5 right
and what do you think about move F6 it's
always such an
ugly looking move when you push the F
Pawn
Grand Master feingles has never play F6
he's got a point you're right he but
it's a very very specific idea that
Wesley is doing he's trying you you
you're right I could play the movie
should be seven invite Bishop takes E7
Queen takes E7 and as we can see from
our database tons and tons of games but
the idea behind Knight H5 and F6 is he
really does want to chase down this
bishop now residing on H4 and he plays
the move G6 how do you hunt the bishop
Knight G7 95.5 it's it's slow it's slow
it's slow but if I do get to play
eventually Knight F5 takes H4 or Knight
F5 takes G3 mission accomplish whatever
that means right and uh Bishop E2 and we
caught up with the players is this still
Theory VAR as far as you're aware that
uh the London London players are happy
campers
yeah it's it's still a theory there
there are some games still played not so
many games in this position and uh here
C takes D4 is the main move here I see
about nine games in my database
um it's it's just a playable position
but the one a game actually caught my
eye the ACT went for that exchange
sacrifice yeah so let's take a look yes
um
how exciting so he took with the queen
on C3 and now Bishop B4 is played wow
and uh he took Queen takes D5 and he's
gonna play probably the move B5 I think
it's very important to remove the knight
from C6 and after Knight E7
just to go castles he took his time but
he went for this plan and the evaluation
shows uh zeros but I think after 94
Bishop F3 it's going to be easier to
play with the white pieces here also you
have the option to bring the Rook to C1
or even on A1 in this position also I
think when we are exchanged down and
engine shows zeros that's a good sign
it's a very very good sign and that's a
I don't think that's a judgment call per
se I think that there's some preparation
you don't just sacrifice and exchange
against the Challenger to the world
champion and say I'll figure it out I
think they are actually uh prepped uh
some of this stuff so as we get ready uh
for our first break I also want to point
out that dingler in did play that move
around three that varusian was
mentioning that The Rook kind of uh
Rovers Rook up to A3 and then over
whether it to be to the C3 or unusual to
develop The Rook first before the night
exactly but this is an unusual position
it's truly uh nice and as we get uh to
our first break I'd just like to say
hello to our good friends at Q Boutique
we have some today's special I want to
say here's your chance to get a limited
edition t-shirt commemorating the World
Chess hall of fames current exhibit mind
art experience 10 years of Chess and
culture in St Louis the unique the
unique shirt features a drawing of the
world's largest chess piece and the
World Chess Hall of Fame building in St
Louis it is exclusively available at
cubatique St louis.com and as we do go
to break we ask the players how they
feel about returning to Romania and
playing in what appears to be some
really excellent conditions
these are their answers
[Music]
this is the fourth year we're playing
here in Bucharest Romania what do you
enjoy about being back here in Bucharest
to Kickstart the grandchester
I I like to see a lot I've been to
Bucharest not only the four times that
the grand just tour has been here but
also twice in 2012 and 2013 so six times
total and um yeah it's always great to
be here I like the country I like the
city it's it's a really vibrant City I
mean big cities have their own kind of
special energy and I guess I'm not like
always so used to I grew up in New York
which has like a very similar energy but
in St Louis it's a bit more of like a
medium-sized City so it's a lot more
calm when you go out you don't always
see like a million people but that has
its own charm as well yeah bucharesta
obviously I I switched to federations to
Romania
um so this is a my second tournament
here in Bucharest but my first one is
playing on the Romania flag yeah
Bucharest is a very special place
um there are not many tournaments were
happening here but now it's really
amazing and really
um well organized everything I love the
city the people are great here very
helping people and everywhere we go we
have good times so I'm very happy yeah
and I know that Bucharest is considered
to be Paris of the East right okay
because I play at home
it's more supporting Romania than other
countries
looks a bit more important for me I
really like the city this process super
surprisingly
surprisingly nice I like like their
architecture yes like some weather is
quite quite mild and warm uh so yeah I
guess uh we'll take only good emotions
from here I'm really happy to be back to
Bucharest I was here already two times
and every time I come back you know the
organizers they only
improving and um
building on what they've done and
Bucharest
for these two weeks of the capital of
the the Chess World and in general with
so many events happening in Romania and
so much chess life around here because
it's turning into a you know a big big
Center of jazz activity and that's
wonderful to see yeah it's my third time
in Bucharest and I I enjoy it it's very
comfortable to be here there are many
people speaking French as well so it's
it does feel very comfortable other than
that obviously like during the
tournament I prioritize the tournament
and not sightseeing and such but uh no
it's still very good to get some fresh
air to to go outside we're in very
Central locations so that's also nice oh
it's lovely it's my fourth year here I
can't become a tradition I've really
enjoyed coming here since
2019 and the people are really friendly
I meet again the people I usually meet I
have some friends here so it's it's a
lovely wonderful hopefully my play would
be up to par with it and that's the
reason why I came
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back to our live coverage of
round two of the Bucharest Romania Grand
chest tour as a round two has been
underway and this game between world
champion ding Loren and Bobby uh
could potentially end in a remarkable
repetition wow uh just while we were on
break the night is on C6 and they have
seen the move Knight C5 the Knight on C6
is protected by the queen on C2 so the
Knight on C5 temporarily
stops the defense of that night and that
is the exchange of knights that Fabi
would like uh to happen I think so they
are repeating yes so after the move
Knight C5 ding Loren did not want to
acquiesce to the trade of knights he
brought his Knight back to B4 and then
Fabi brought his Knight back to B7 now
the night on B4 is misplaced what's it
doing there the pawns is going to go to
C5 the Knight might go to d8 leaving the
night on C6 stranded and that is why we
are seeing a repetition and I don't know
if they made three move repetition
already before
dingler in this is this is not exactly
what he had hoped he starts the
tournament with two whites he has the
number one draw the number one number
in the drawing of lots he starts with
two whites yesterday he didn't put
enough pressure I want to say on mvl and
today a very well prepared fobby is
having an easy time at the office right
for absolutely yes sir yeah this is the
moment here if dink uh plays Knight C6
now again it will be a three-fold
repetition and I think he missed an
opportunity earlier we can take a look
when he played the move Bishop G5 I
think this move was an inaccuracy uh
right here if he had played the smooth
92 I really like this move I think he
would have a secure a slightly better
position after that line with Knight d8
taking only seven and playing the move
B3 with the bishop A3 idea so perhaps
when he played the move Bishop G5 here
he
uh didn't expect to move H6 H6 is a very
very precise move and uh it looks like
it just equalizes the game because
after you take on F6 and this Knight C5
resource it's possible that he maybe
missed the move Knight C5 it's a really
nice idea by karwana and looks like he's
still in prep perhaps he analyzed this
whole thing actually he still has this
in his file
so Bishop F6 we saw here and
you know you can play E3 in this
position this is an option two but again
it looks like this is the the same idea
you still have to play Knight C5 here to
try to get rid of the Knight on C6 here
right and if you go to B4 then you just
go back on B7 now you're threatening to
play the move C5 once you play C5 then
you have your Rook coming up on the C
file as well so I expect the ding just
to repeat because he's also down half an
hour on the clock at this moment so I so
they already repeat it a few times so
let's see Knight C6
and uh yeah this is the moment yeah he
doesn't really have that many options if
he doesn't play the move Knight C6 for
example if he plays Queen C6 try to put
the queen on C6 then actually Queen E7
comes in now black is already better
here now the Knight is under attack and
uh if you play Knight C2 the Knight
comes to A5 removing the queen and again
C5 will come next and black is uh doing
really well here and I don't see any
other options here for him but to play
the move knight uh C6 here and I think
it will lead to just a draw
thank you VAR and turning to our
tournament leader for a moment uh Wesley
so has played the move C5 takes D4 and
after C5 takes D4 Knight takes D4 Knight
to G7 that whole idea once again of just
playing Knight F4 hunting down the two
Bishops and uh mvl took a I want to say
a sharp turn
after you play the move Knight takes C6
B take C6 you're you're you're kind of
thinking fine fine fine but that capture
on C6 actually has a very long-term
impact the sense is that the pawn on C6
gets to play a role in the center
in this Central Pawn Mass Sicilian
players are going to really enjoy having
those types of central Palm masses
combined with a half open B file but mvl
had a very clear idea he wanted to stop
the move Knight F5 so that he could play
the move E3 E4 he's helped black
structure but at the same time he
stopped his main idea and after E4 I
think we have car up and this is the
shocking Life Time matchup because
nobody has this good a score against
Wesley so I don't even think Magnus is
this uh close 20 draws that's a lot I
must say they have played each other a
lot yes six wins uh and like I was
saying if Wesley gets through today's
challenge having won yesterday watch out
uh he remarkably
mvl is the the defending champion of the
request and my my pick and your pick
and he won the 2022 event by beating
Wesley so oh oh well Wesley and the
vulneronian was one of his uh victims
and here at our standings after the
first round right after round one we
have a leader with one point was Lisa
who defeated alireza yesterday and the
rest of the four matches ended in a draw
nice now I'd like to ask you your
personal opinion I'm looking at the game
of Wesley so and there's no way I'm
going to mess up my center by capturing
and letting you play Knight takes E4
forget about it it's not gonna happen
but what I am going to do is go Bishop
E7 now if you had
the right to choose either side uh would
you rather play White would you rather
play black and white I would definitely
pick white you would yes
because I'm not that comfortable with
this structure that black has chosen in
this position uh with E4 I'm not
planning to take on D5 you're not for
sure do me a favor making me play B7
take C6 takes D5 thank you for that no
what are you what's your plan I'm Gonna
Keep the
and I wonder what mvl is thinking
regarding Castle in probably short
Castle probably right okay so castles
castles everybody's happy
and we do have an advantage on the queen
side in the sense that we have three
pawns versus two you've got the queen
side majority I've got the central
majority you've got the queen side
majority I'll give you that but I'm not
sure if white should be playing on the
queen side or maybe try playing you mean
like b4a4 Knight B3 or you were about to
suggest F4 but I can play it right away
King is exposed
Expo
be walking into Queen I I see a cookie I
see a check and a potential Queen takes
pizza so you gotta kind of delay playing
maybe I'm not sure it's that desirable
but maybe F4 yeah right so that would be
a little bit slow I think to play King
H1 and F4 right so maybe just Queen C2
and centralized okay okay so Queen C2
centralize the Rooks gotcha I'm
concerned about one thing what's that am
I blundered in a piece
maybe right maybe what takes on e4 and
then G5 G5 and F5 that was why I was
setting you up actually for this you're
absolutely right that was where I was
heading G5 Bishop G3 let me take whether
you take well you can't really take with
a queen that blunder is a piece right
away but if you did take with the Knight
the idea was to play F5 and F4 and if
you if you tickled my queen I don't care
something like this I could I don't know
Bishop D7 the idea was I was playing for
a peace trap which means I don't and I
don't think you wanted to do this right
again this trade seems so helpful to uh
the black side especially if I could
play Knight F5 the reason why I like to
play Black in such positions is because
I have this French defense Caro
like history of my career where I played
right through the center and I love
these big big centers you know if I
could go E6 E5 and you know F6 F5 and
get you know three three Pawns of rest
uh in the center of the board I agree
with that but I'm so uncomfortable with
the Knight on G7 unless it makes it to
F5 right I'm very unhappy with the
Knight well but it it it's uh it's not
going to be waiting there too long I
mean it's it's ready to jump
um as we've been debating the pros and
cons of the position of varusian why
don't we ask the 3200 engine uh to split
the tie
who what does the engine say about
Wesley's position well engines think
Bach is doing absolutely fine actually
yeah so perhaps even preferable because
of the central possibility of playing E5
and getting the control of the center I
can show you some of the lines now
please so um yeah so the one of the best
moves is actually to play Queen A4 here
try to put some pressure on uh C6 and
now Bishop D7 right and after Castle
Blackwell castle and you do you do have
this option E5 coming up very soon and
usually like uh when you put the Rook on
the queen will go to C7 it's a good
Square for the queen now you connect
your Rooks
and it's not so clear to see how uh
White is going to continue here as you
mentioned you never really want to take
on the fight because after C takes D5
now the queen is under attack also and
now black will have a complete control
of the center so this will be a really
bad
um a position for for white here and you
can play for example Bishop F3
and now just even King h8 for example
you can you can really take on D5 and
you don't have that many options at some
point this Knight will come into the
game either to F5 or after E5 you will
play the move 96 so I think Wesley is
pretty happy after the opening outcome I
think he doesn't have any problems here
and perhaps he could have some
opportunities
um there is another game that caught my
eye I wanted to show you the game
between a report and Duda here and we
know a report is very original player
and uh he played Queen D3 here after
Bishop G5 sorry he played Bishop G7 was
trading I placed them with Queen E3
check
so and you cannot really play Queen E7
here because if you do that after simply
capture on E7
King takes E7 you're losing your yeah
Bishop D5 you're losing the Central Pawn
because you're pinned now on F6 so
actually black had to play the move King
f8 but it's not that bad because the
position is closed here and at some
point maybe Rook will come with the
tempo and now we see the move Knight A4
a clever move try to trade this Knight
and now the the point is to play Queen
A3 here
um again black is a very very solid here
it does doesn't give white much
Advantage so H6 is played here now
attacking on the bishop I was looking at
the lines after Knight takes
A4 right then there's Queen A3 check
and you can play Queen E7 for example
Queen takes A4 and now you have H6 you
can also play C6 in this position just
to protect the D5 Pawn but now after H6
if you take on F6 Bishop takes F6 again
if you don't take on D5 black will just
play C6 and it doesn't have any problems
right and if you take now and if you
excuse me if you take on D5 now after
Rook d8 black would have a very
dangerous initiative here because he
will be able to capture on D4 with the
tempo and the bishopon F6 is very well
placed and you still have your king only
once so the position is about equal but
I think it could be some some initiative
here for black so it's a very solid
position I think Duda is doing fine here
back to you thank you uh for across the
board I'm saying really good Fighting
Chess and all kinds of openings I want
to come to the game between anash Gary
and our top seed alireza uh it was a
quiet
uh exchange love usually that's a a sign
that a draw may be in the offing but
because of
Anish is provocative play in the opening
there's imbalances that have suddenly
occurred after the move A7 A6 keep in
mind that this bishop on B4 very nicely
uh attacks this pin Knight on C3 well
let me return the favor on the king side
your Bishop on B4 is not on E7 so that
Knight on F6 is in a pin and if I'm
white I want I desperately want to play
95 and F4 and the Harry Nelson Pillsbury
uh 19th century uh American player he
loved the Pillsbury attack which Bears
his Knight upon
Lee Knight F4 F4 and if you let me get
in all of these attacking moves that
Bishop on H4 is really really annoying
uh suddenly the the game is you know in
One Direction the other problem that
black is having although I don't know if
it's necessarily a threat Bishop takes
F6
G takes F6 you can't recapture the queen
because of this forlorn Bishop on D7
keeping that in mind farooges move A6
prep the move Bishop B5 I think the main
idea is to get rid of the white square
Bishop that's a very good attacker
against Black's King precisely that
Bishop on D7 is rather septic it's not
having a very good role in the position
that the bishop on D3 you're absolutely
right is doing great uh yeoman's work on
the long diagonals we see the lifetime
only two games not much this is still
surprising but I'm sure they will have a
lot more games I think so too as Ali
raise a returning to defend his Grand
chest Tour Championship Crown Bishop B5
now here I must admit if I was wide
I'd be tempted by doubling the pawns
but I'd also be tempted by playing the
move F4 right away so yeah I mean
it looks slow and trust me it is slow
but absolutely F3 yeah so but if you let
me build up this type of an attack by
the time it arrives there's just no
defense right so uh the temptation of
playing F4 allowing the trade yes you
could capture on C3 yes I would be
forced to make a a weakness on the
e-force white squares are really weak C4
and E4 but I don't think
they might not matter at this point yeah
it might be all about the black king I'm
gonna you know go uh as we might say
Whole Hog Anish Gary actually didn't do
that he captured immediately took and
he's thinking
um
I'm almost I I'm always impressed by
these top guys who they play this
prophylactic chest where they don't
commit themselves to playing a move like
F4 words I'm the type of player that is
like go for it play F4 and attack I
suspect the engine doesn't like F4 uh
but I gotta ask you VAR could he go for
it with F4 yeah let's check the move
with that for uh White does have some
Advantage here there are a few ways he
can play here I will show you but let's
check the move F4 before taking the
bishop on B5 right yes sir yeah so if we
play F4 here yeah engine doesn't like it
as much it thinks black is just
comfortable after taking on C3 right and
it's it's very concrete and now you have
the smooth Queen C7 just targeting the
C3 pawn and allowing the bishop takes F6
okay so let's say Bishop takes F6 G
takes F6 and the Knight is under attack
Knight G4 Knight G4 and now he he's
recommending F5 wow because if you take
the pawn on H6 then the Knight is
trapped
you you do have some compensation you
can play like Knight xf5
uh Pawn takes F5 take on B5 for example
that's a lovely King yes and then you
have Queen takes F5 but uh it shows a
black is actually slightly better it's
it's not that the attack is not that
dangerous even though we see that Rook
F3 Rook G3 is coming up yeah
as well he recommends the move Rook G8
now Rook G8 with idea to attacking the
King on ff8 and uh he thinks it's just
it's okay for black disposition but uh
Anish has a another idea I think now how
he can obtain a small Advantage here I
will show you please uh instead of the
move F4 uh here he already took on B5
right uh so let's go back
so here actually it's very important to
realize you don't really want to take on
F6 even though it looks like you're
forcing the move GTX F6 because if you
take back with the queen now you're
losing the exchange after Knight D7
clear so you might be tempted to take on
F6 but the problem is this Knight is
actually well placed and when you take
on F6 you're allowing GTX F6 and now you
have to move the knight from um E5 and
again this I think same idea will apply
here if you if you go Knight H5 you run
into the problem here actually after H5
your knight is trapped in this line so
Knight H6 just King G7 so you have to
play the move Knight D3 now right and
there will be a bishop takes C3
and pawn takes C3 and Knight finally
comes to a good Square it's been sitting
there on the side of the board on A5 and
now comes in on C4 and here well
actually black is doing absolutely fine
in this position
which is really crazy for me thank you
for that I would and by the way the Fabi
ending and looks like both players are
waiting for the Arbiter to make a claim
of a three-time repetition
and I'm sure that will be the first
result of round two as dingler in with
the white pieces
um and here's the handshake and there's
the handshake a draw now everything you
just said
um VAR as I catch up with the point that
you were making Bishop takes F6 G takes
F6 Knight D3 if I were in black shoes
Bishop takes CD3 I would see
not a good night on C4 but two pairs
that's exactly what I
um the first pair of double pawns on the
queen side I might not really care that
much about because I see that Knight D6
it's the second pair on the king side
that concerned me I would be really
really scared that my king is vulnerable
to an E3 E4 and that this Pawn on G7
belongs on G7 not on F6 and I would be
afraid that my opponent would have a a
long-term advantage and you're saying
nothing to worry about it's even Steven
yeah absolutely it just shows wow equal
and maybe even slightly preferable for
black but from a human point of view
yeah you could you could definitely go
for this position but there is another
line where I think white will have a
slightly better position so I will show
you now how uh Anish can obtain a small
edge here instead of taking on F6 he can
play this move Knight G4 okay which is a
kind of a typical idea in the slav
exchange positions like this where you
already have the bishop on H4 and now
you want to take on F6
and if with the Knight and damage the
structure so you really have to play
this move Bishop B7 now and now he can
simplify the position take on F6 twice
Bishop takes F6 and now the black has a
strong threat of B4 and uh you need to
move the queen away now you have this
move Queenie too right now the B5 Pawn
is under attack so power will be forced
and now you put the Knight on A4
and here actually white will have some
Advantage Queen E7 and you play B3 and
now the Knight on A5 can never go to C4
and you have some Queen B5 ideas the
pawns on B7 and before a little bit weak
so Rook fc1 is coming up so it's a
long-term Advantage I think uh something
like this could be quite unpleasant and
from The Experience playing a lot of the
slav exchange positions sometimes this
is a dream position that you can get you
have a small Advantage but you can try
to improve your position and to have
good chances to win not a good start for
Ali Reza and let's jump to Bucharest as
Christian is with Fabia for a podcast
we don't have a podcast yes sir right
now scheduled but we do have an
interview because Fabiano just finished
his game against the newly crowned world
champion dingley ran first of all Fabi
welcome uh to the show tell us a bit
about your approach to this particular
game well let's talk about yesterday as
well because you played Bogdan Daniel
the act the lowest rate the player in
the event and he did surprise him and
got some nice Advantage at least a
practical Advantage out of the opening
did you feel that was a success and
did you miss any chances in yesterday's
game yeah I think the opening he knew
relatively well more or less like he
played a good line and he equalized
um but at some point he played a very
very bad move like it was an equal
position for pretty much the entire game
although I guess he was starting to get
a bit under pressure especially with
time and then he played Bishop page five
which is a very bad move and I responded
also with a very bad move and after
Bishop I'm probably winning if I take on
C5 it should be a winning position
but afterwards he wanted to get nothing
and and then he played well in in time
travel so yeah yesterday was
unfortunately a big pretty big missed
chance but today
um with the black pieces against dingley
Wren we know how much residual opening
preparation he might have coming from
the world championship match what was
the strategy were you trying to surprise
him early on in the opening it felt like
you did
yeah I'm not sure he actually has
anything from the match like my
impression is that he had no ideas at
the end of the match at some point they
ran out and he
he's not really like
trying very hard at the start of this
tournament maybe he's still trying to
recover some energy but yesterday he
didn't really try very hard like against
black Seaman today as well I played a
very very unusual line let's talk about
it
um did he surprise you at all with the
Catalan or was that something that you
were more or less I thought that he
could play first move C4 and I decided
to surprise him a bit by playing what
Young played against him in the tiebreak
and there instead of D4 he played B3
but it led to a very very dry end game
so that's why I I wasn't surprised that
he would go for the catalog
and
so it was one of like the main things I
thought could happen today
and okay the 96 is a super rare move I
think he's faced it before against young
um
or no sorry not against Fusion frusia
played against him I'm not sure that
might have been a Blitz game but
uh or maybe rap game but it's a very
rare line alireza likes it that's it's
basically his line uh computers don't
like it but it's it's not bad at all and
I think I played a novelty with Queen D7
I think that game was Queen E8 against
um Queen 38 yeah
he was thinking a long time maybe he was
trying to recall exactly the details of
the line uh Queen E7 is a new move and
what is the main difference between the
smooth Queen D7 and queen to E8 I mean
the main point of the position is that
black is worse unless you're just larger
than knight from C6 like the nice is is
very dangerous
um but white lacks some development to
keep the Knight on C6 so one of the main
ideas for black is to play Bishop C5 at
some moment uh and for example Queen to
E8 has the idea
of playing Bishop C5 but avoiding Knight
E5 after Queen Seven but Queen D7 is is
still preparing Bishop C5 that's why
white plays Rook T1 so Bishop c595
and our Rook fc8 is
um
sort of like it's it's kind of a useful
move uh the point is white can't develop
so easily without allowing uh because
Knight C3 hangs the the Knight
um Knight takes E7 like it's C5 very
quickly so this is probably probably
nothing yeah it could sound like Bishop
Bishop H6 or H6 first yeah but in
usually white wants to maintain his
Knight and so very critical move is
Knight to D2
because of why it gets just like one
more move to play Knight F3 here black
is in like very serious positional
trouble and so black should play Bishop
C5 the point being that 95 now uh Queen
takes D4 is as possible and then this is
this is like a very critical line
and V4 and uh rook d8 bc5 and Knight D6
um and yeah like for example the
computer I see here shows that black is
much worse with various moves but it is
objectively okay and it's very sharp
it's very risky of course because
Black's King side is damaged
um white could develop an attack but
somehow black is always in time because
at night it becomes very active once it
gets top five so okay this was
a very critical line in Bishop G5 I
think he
basically showed that he was ready to
maybe call it a day or yeah it's the
safest move it trades a lot of pieces I
thought that he would actually go for
this one
because if c5d5
um
yeah and I think like one of the moves
was Queen to E7 I think this was okay
um like I remembered I think this line
is C5 G5 and Knight to A5 allowing in D6
which was kind of possible
oh yeah D6 D6 somehow it's not very good
for white and
um
yeah I mean black has many approaches so
I was going to to think
in case we got here because I
didn't really check this position I just
knew that this was one of the ways for
white to get like a very slightly better
position
um and then he decided to uh I think he
he kind of thought this was interesting
for white
somebody had to put the Rook on C3 maybe
take yeah like Knight d8 Rook C3 I think
that this is basically his dream and one
of the important points is that for
example if I play Bishop B7 and Bishop
C5 it just doesn't work because Queen E4
um otherwise he would have to retrieve
his Rook here and maybe I would equalize
but I mean Knights if I was the first
one which came to mind and it just took
a little bit of time to
just make sure you're not blundering
anything and well just some details like
for example Rook D3 I think yeah there's
probably A5 but also I was
I was kind of reasonable you I was
actually not 100 sure about this
position because he he sacks upon but he
gets a C4 Square so I was gonna think
after Rook D3 but I thought A5 is
probably
um a clean bailout and yeah there were
probably early moves even like C6 I was
thinking I mean I I just first stop any
invasions on C6 and then chase the night
away
and um he decided to repeat after
thinking for quite a long time yeah were
you expecting him to try to continue in
any way shape or form or I was hoping I
was hoping you were hoping I was hoping
because
um like I can't really deviate here I
don't have a way I think I
um without getting a worse position or
or at least a slightly worse position
but he has some like some ways which
look interesting after an ib7 yeah and
uh
it's kind of it's a little bit
disappointing I guess to make a draw
with white so early so I was hoping
maybe his uh his kind of ambition would
carry him forward a bit but
um
and okay he's a bit lower on time so I
maybe I would get a game but uh I wasn't
too surprised that he repeated because
it it does start to look a bit risky
with your knight on B1 kind of just it's
not in the game so you're you're not
really in the position to play on for
Your Balanced start to uh this
tournament we'll see you in the next
round thanks
thank you Christian thank you Fabi
question for you yes are you a Material
Girl I like being material ahead
yes okay it depends
I want to turn your attention to the
game of dioc versus yon for just a
moment diox sacrificed in exchange for
the two Bishops in a poem do you find it
easier to play The Exchange up or with
the Bishops
in this position
exchange you would take that there yeah
you are a material girl that we saw the
move h2h3 which maybe that's not
what sometimes you gotta hit the Anvil
while it's hot and in this particular
case I would find the moves Bishop G4
and Bishop F3 far more compelling
because I'm afraid when I'm down
material that if I don't
um
equalize the material right that in the
long term I could have a problem and I
find the move h2h3 just a little bit
lackadaisical uh uh VAR was H3 a good
move
uh I agree with you yesterday H3 I don't
like it as much uh he could have
actually played the move Bishop C40
Bishop C4 putting pressure on the queen
and it's not so clear where to put the
queen because if you go to G6 then I
have Bishop D3 so it's possible to even
get some repetition there Bishop C4
Queen G6 so let's take a look here so
for example Bishop C4
if he had played this move now where to
put the queen you don't have really good
squares here you don't really want to
play Queen F6 here because after
exchange of the Queens your structure is
really really bad here and I can't even
play the move G4 and you probably get
dropping the H6 Pawn so it'll be a very
very strong compensation here and white
is actually a slightly better here right
so you can't just exchange coins because
you're up exchange because two Bishops
are very very strong here so if you play
Queen E4 I actually can just if I want
to draw I can just repeat
and now you can just go away because F5
is hanging so if you go to D5 and I just
continue attacking your queen again
there's a little little trick here a
little trip boy if you play a queen C5
then you lose the game to a bishop F7
check oops because this Knight is not
very uh stable on F5 so you can you can
try to force a repetition I don't know
if the attack is maybe playing for a win
doesn't want to repeat same thing goes
here if you go Queen G6 again I can play
the move Bishop D3 for example now again
you're pinned and if you play it okay C8
then you run into the problem of a move
like Queen E5 now you're losing the
Knight exactly so
H3 it gives him a little break now
and now uh I think nepo just played Rook
fd8 right another option he had in this
position he could have played Rook fc8
after H3
uh again it looks like engine's top move
was rook fc8 in this position but now he
plays this move and perhaps he has some
ideas with a move like Knight D4 Knight
D4 let's say if you make a slow move
now comes in so it's a logical move I
like rookie FDA controlling the open
file and we know that's where the Rooks
belong and now he also wants to play the
move through Casey next yeah back to you
guys easy uh easy game there I'd like to
turn our attention to the very creative
game that's going on between Richard and
aduda but it really seems to me that
this there's some artificial artifice
that's going on here on the white side
is Richard you know is trying to do
things and not getting anywhere frankly
after this move at first looks very
creative Knight A4 uh black took the
approach and said well wait a minute you
don't want to take on B6
I guess you want to play Knight C5 but
I was afraid of hanging the pawn on D5
earlier when I played the move H7 H6 I
don't have to worry about that let's
just put the question to the bishop if
you capture well now I get to Cat Castle
by hand very nicely King G7 rookie eight
and I gotta say I think black is for
choice in that particular case so
Richard said okay
uh Queen A3 as these guys are evenly
matched very even two wins two
uh Queen A3 check on the board and I say
I really admire how Richard rapid plays
yes so original
I don't think you avoid necessarily
avoids Theory but he creates his own
theories he does he does and uh he he
brings it but it oftentimes happens that
the most original players are their own
worst enemies they they they they they
start thinking more and more and more
about what they're doing
chess is a fight and your opponent
sometimes doesn't read the same script
so while you're doing everything that
you think is actually wonderful
oftentimes you can overdo it and
Overlook what the opponent has and
that's what I wanted to say about the
current position after the move Queen E7
I think black is just absolutely solved
all of his problems obviously with the
move Queen E7 I'm more than eager to
capture on A3 doubling up these pawns if
that were to provoke Queen takes King
takes now you gotta stop because two
pieces are hanging this part the pardon
me the bishop on it G5 between moves to
fix that yes but Bishop takes F6 a lot
of exchanges
well that's interesting that you put it
like that because these exchanges and
probably are going to be favorable for
black you got to take on B6 otherwise D4
is hanging right so you take on E6 I
take with the a pawn now if you don't
take on D5
well maybe after I don't know King D6 B5
I prefer blacks yes precisely so you
take on D5
I take maybe I toss in Rook d8 or or C6
I'm not
actually that sure maybe it's the six to
not give up the pawn them well I'm
pursuing what I consider an initiative
here that I think okay let me let me try
to show you what I mean Rook d8 Bishop
take let's go Rook A7
F3
so I'm not letting you Castle not long
not long that's right and if I Castle
short you have Rook D2 Bingo and who has
the initiative in that case definitely
black A2 C2 B2 are all hanging so this
is what I mean when I say I think
there's a possibility that Richard got
too creative and at the end of the day
it might be Duda who is uh I might have
a slight event yeah who could
potentially push no we had the players
on the camera if we try to read their
body language it definitely looked like
Richard was not too happy with the
position he got out of the opening and
Duda feels pretty comfortable and maybe
he's thinking should I go for more are
you aware of your opponent's body
language during it all the time
absolutely you kind of flicker an eye
across the board there you see your
opponent slouched in his head in their
laps and he was like Okay it definitely
helps and I also try to maintain my
composure to not let my opponent know
what I what's going on with me exactly
exactly but it's hard to hide it yeah
you know you blundered a rook that that
red glow comes to the face uh jump in
VAR what has caught your eye
um I was also looking at this game you
guys were analyzing I think there's a
good chance that probably this game is
going to face a lot to a draw I will
show a couple of lines here first so in
this position I think white needs to
take only seven here I don't really want
to allow the move Queen A3 in this
position so after you take only seven
King takes E7 and now Knight B6 is
forced because your Bishop is hanging
now on G5 and again Knight B6 is the
kind of move you don't really want to do
you would have loved to play the move
Knight C5 in this position but here you
simply can because you can lose the
bishop right so you're forced to take on
B6 and I think after a takes B6 you
don't really have a good way to you can
play Bishop F4 but after C6 you always
have to worry about the Knight coming to
E4 there is no Advantage so after take I
think we could say something like this
happening like E3 will be played
protective four C6 and then like A3 B5
C3 and uh it's just going to be a
completely equal position neither side
can really make progress so I predict
that this is probably going to be a draw
they might follow something like this
but let's take a look at the Wesley's
game against mvl because something
very aggressive was played here by mvl
he played the move F4 here and this
weakens the position here of this
diagonal Here and Now Queen B6 was
played but I don't I think this is the
most accurate move here he could have
played either Castle
or the move Queen C7 here very concrete
move now putting pressure on F4 and I
kind of like this move because now you
need to protect this and now after
Castle I can play castle as well
definitely I think black has some
chances after the move F4 some winning
chances because position now has been
weakened but he played the move Queen B6
so after this one I think the problem
here is sometimes you're gonna run into
the move Bishop F2 now coming in with
the tempo so for example Queen C2 could
be played and if you castle and you can
play the mubish beef too now rerouting
the bishop to on this diagonal in this
case probably black will play Queen C7
again attacking the pawn on F4 Bishop E3
just to protect and here black has
different options it's uh it's about
equal but again it's very small Edge
perhaps for black you can play even move
C5 here
the possibility of this Knight coming in
on F5 I think will be really strong so I
think Wesley should be very happy with
the outcome of this of of this opening
so far
thank you uh VAR uh another player who
may be very happy about the outcome of
the opening is Anish Gary versus Ali
Reza uh so I got that position we're
talking about precisely uh when we left
it we had just traded on B5 had a niche
uh I was in vote invoking the ghost of
Harry Nelson Pillsbury with the move F4
and Rook F3 but VAR was the first to
point out that there is a fork on D7 so
that after the move Bishop takes F6 the
desirable Queen takes F6 loses an
exchange that provoked farrugia to
double us pawns on the king side
injuring the Pond Shield of his own King
Knight D3 attacking the bishop on a B4
Bishop takes B uh C3 B takes C3 as you
were about to say they got to the
position well they're about to get to
the position after Knight C4 and this is
where you and I looked at each other and
said my goodness we like White's
position and this is where the engine in
its cold-blooded calculation said
nothing told us that engine says
nobody believes you what yeah it's hard
to believe yeah it really really is I
think we have A4 on the board so Anisha
is exchanging at least one pair of
double ones and uh I guess that's good
for black they only have to worry about
the F7 F6 yes exactly I I I see this
move as just like a slow burn
essentially
if I were white I'd be really really
anxious I would want to put my knight on
F
4 and the Knight goes to age five so
that I could immediately take advantage
of what I consider a very vulnerable
King position the move a2a4 is one of
those very typically restrained top
Grand Master moves where you say
the advantage on the king side is not
going away black is not going to
single-handedly saw his his King side
position in the meanwhile maybe the A2
Pawn is not as good as the B5 Pawn you
know open the a file maybe have a good
day open a and b files for his Rooks if
you wanted to exactly uh if he doesn't
believe there's too much on the king
side that he can do then he can focus on
the queen side yeah and uh VAR back over
to you yeah uh there's actually a very
funny move in this position if we go
back uh I want to show yes I think you
may like this idea so sure uh in a game
uh Anish versus ferocia so Bishop takes
F6 again we were looking at the Knight
G4 option here where I think white has a
really nice Advantage but after Bishop
takes F6 she takes F6 actually white has
this move Knight G6
because I know you mentioned earlier you
want to put a knight on F4 right so if
the Rook was only eight you actually
just can play Knight F4 it doesn't
really give uh an accelerator Advantage
but at least you gain a Tempe and now
you can put the Knight on F4 but we can
take a look what happens if it takes for
example so white actually doesn't have
that that much you know has to just take
on G6 and to take on H6 and it looks
like we have to actually give the
Perpetual with Queen G6 Queen H6 because
if black plays the move Rook C7 then
bring it to G7 he will he will have the
advantage so it was just a the nice idea
that he had this move Knight G6 Resource
as far as the move A4 I like this move
because uh A2 Pawn is isolated and I
think he wants to exchange with a Pawn
on B5 and hoping that some some Rooks
will come off the board and I think if
we get a position within a night on F4
maybe bring the queen to E2 Queen G4
Knight H5 maybe this is what Anish is
hoping for to try to get a little bit of
an advantage nice thank you VAR as I
again I'm bringing out the material in
uh both of ourselves I'm looking at the
game of nepo and diac when we left it we
saw the move h2h3 Rook d8 I like this uh
point that uh VAR was making that 94 is
actually a rather awkward looking move
Bishop G4 could be met by Queen takes G4
in those kinds of circumstances so
Knight D4 on Black's agenda Bishop F3
Rook C8 Queen A5 and dioc is definitely
targeting uh the queen side pawns A7 and
B7 are both hanging and for the moment
those Bishops really make a very
powerful impression and I I if I were
blood here what yes I would probably go
for G5 but first i'm considering to play
B6 right give up the A7 Pawn okay and
then play G5 all right chasing the
bishop back right so White Queen is
really far away and I want to focus on
the king side
okay uh understood maybe Knight H4 all
right all right uh fair fair and the
idea is you want to Chase my Bishop away
Initiative for black so I'm I'm
following my gut feeling okay exactly
all right and I feel you I'm a little
bit reluctant to play a move like Bishop
C6 which might walk into Rook take C6
and then G2 you you mentioned my queen
being uh most especially out of the game
so in this particular case imagine I
were to play uh a move Bishop B7 it
looks a little bit funny that I'm I'm
inviting Rook D7 or queen D7 or
something like that here I think I
five possibly Rook C5
just in case that if I push G4 I might
need a rook on G5 exactly so again I
have got two Pawns
for an exchange but the Knight on H4
tickling me on G2 is uh in the words of
Victor korchnoy unpleasant Sensations I
might want to get rid of that night
you're maybe welcome to win that pawn I
don't know maybe I can jump back Knight
of five right for now and then take the
pawn right
so
here it's quite passive I know it
doesn't it
um here I've got one of these uh I I
kind of call them cocoons right these
ideas where I've got a pawns on G2 G3 H3
and it cocoons my king in a very nice
way uh with some beautiful
games of Vichy and man and open
Sicilians where he's castled Queen side
as white
he's recaptured on B3 with a C2 pawn and
then he puts his
King on a tune where it was beautifully
sheltered and he goes mad House Coffee
House on the king side yeah here Black's
only weaknesses upon on F7 right so if I
can deal with that then I would love to
get both of my Rooks on the second rank
yes but I do have thank goodness uh very
good yeah that's a very good defensive
piece but I hear what you're saying that
the move G you would only play a move
like G5 not be it wins or something like
that that that's very clear but you
would play a move like G5 when you feel
you can or should be trying to seize the
initiative right I was also inspired by
Wesley yesterday when he played G5 at
the right moment he did yeah yeah and
got his victory so G7 G5 okay again to
remind those player viewers pardon me
who may be joining us late we only have
one result so far an early draw between
dingler in and Fabi uh well played but
we also want to invite you to join the
conversation and uh oh and look at the
very wow there's a lot of ways to get a
hold of it right
Twitter or Facebook Instagram YouTube
twitch
Stomp the panel right just look us up
with hashtag super bad chess classic
yeah on our break then assignment and I
think that there's a lot of comments
that right that they're sitting through
Anastasia Carlo which is managing our
social media right grantchester
nice a big shout out to Anastasia uh
Queen B6 by the way our tournament
leader uh it was met by Queen B3 I like
what uh what VAR was saying there that
Queen C7 can't still do it now after
Queen B3 he can go back to Queen C7
because the Cleveland P3 is not
necessarily a well-placed queen exactly
uh Queen goes back to C7 you can pick up
the tempo but now having said that
um
I'm I'm
pause
because I'm looking at this move Queen
E3 like going into the lion's mouth
right like this is the type of move that
can fail miserably like just you know
like trap yeah exactly like like Bishop
F2 Queen takes and somehow there's a
queen trap but it it's also one of those
moves that can be incredibly disruptive
you can't Castle long you can't Castle
short so
I would consider Queen E3 I'd also just
consider castles like I think that's
what he did in the game yeah we have
Castle on the board just say okay you
know
fair you I definitely would I would
I would you know that happened to me in
a game with Gary casparo Right Gary
played one of the worst strategic moves
of his career against me wow yeah and he
turned a good position into a horrible
position with one move
and I was really aware of the time that
he made the move that it was a bad move
but he also did it in a way as screwing
in the the board it wasn't scarletti of
Sweden for the GMA Grand Masters
Association World Cup tournaments and
the Swedish television were was out in
force like just huge cameras in the
playing Hall and when while Gary was
screwing in the Moon it occurred to me
that I should get up from the board go
around the table give him a little kiss
on the cheek thank you for that and then
go sit down except these cameras were
huge they're like one-ton cameras you
know like they were intimidating and I
told Gary after the game that I intended
to make a kiss and he said I deserve it
you should have done it yeah I should
have done it I mean then it would have
been on you know Nightly News you know
Grandmaster famous game ever right
Grandmasters kiss each other at the
board you know like what uh
a strategical howler is to take that is
just helping black enormously the pawn
structure suddenly so beautiful but I
think you get a kiss because black
squares are so weakened for white maybe
white should exchange the coins you
intriguing yeah yeah we have
let's go for it okay here it is
from one gm68 on switch
who is the player of this field you like
the most not from a chess perspective
but from his personality ladies first
what a great question thank you I do
have to think about it I know half of
this players very well right because
we're about the same age and we grew up
around the same time in the Chess World
I have many favorites
but right now I will say dingleren
because last month he won a lot of
people's hearts right he is so humble
and so sweet so I think personally wise
I'm gonna go with dingler
me too for a completely different reason
I kind of grew up with this world of
Chess Titans uh Gods that were just
greater uh than anybody who plays chess
there was the editing enigmatic Bobby
Fisher who maybe had narcissistic
Tendencies but he had an ego and I love
some of Bobby's quotes like Bobby would
say okay but Bobby would be asked you're
the first you're you're number one in
the world by rating who's number two and
Bobby would say no
I'm number two and number three I'm
number one number two number three I'm
the top three places are me and then
there's a guy who's fourth to accentuate
the fact that that was he was a head and
shoulders above everybody else then
there was Gary Kasparov
and Gary had his own way of letting you
know that he was the best player in the
world and there's degler in
with a very very soft spoken voice
saying yes
I tried very hard today I put my energy
my soul into everything I could but it
wasn't enough
and this you never heard in 40 years you
know wow that's so rare how about
yourself or Jump Right In uh to the
viewers question
absolutely I really like dingler and I
think he was very very honest also
during the match revealing you know he
was depressed and you know he mentioned
you know he was going to quit chess if
he didn't win the championship and and
I'm I'm very happy that he won because
he he had this certain things happened
you know he got there somehow and he
took his chance it's so many times
people have opportunities but it's very
hard for them to finish and win the uh
the world championship but he he took a
chance and he won it and I think we're
gonna see a lot more of it you're gonna
get to know him more as a person and
from your interviews and I thought he
was very humble when he won the match
and I really liked his uh final speech
at the closing ceremony yeah absolutely
well you and I
both uh we're very sympathetic picked
thing right yes as far as the uh chess
uh personality because he's just so
unique in this office spoken uh many of
the western players including let's be
honest you know Magnus he kind of thinks
you know like hey man you know like I'm
not world number one I've been world's
number one for 15. he's earned it and so
he's got that ragadacio about him and
again deservedly so I mean uh it's like
Muhammad Ali if you you can walk the
walk and talk the talk you gotta gotta
walk the walk I also liked what a bar
said we do appreciate things honestly
yes we don't hear that often that
players sharing their true raw emotions
right during the tournaments right and
also I just want to point out what you
just referenced in this comment of ding
Loren which was in the interview boy you
know if I lose the match I'm going to
quit chess
because he's so
emotionally driven he has put so much
effort Magnus Carlson played in five
World Championship matches and said okay
I'm going to take a break and everybody
jumped on Magnus and said how dare you
you know history
ding plays one world championship match
says I'm exhausted I'm ready to quit you
take quit chess Magnuson said I'm gonna
quit chess Magnus is playing so you get
an idea just how intense these World
Championship matches are and uh well
okay uh hats off to those players thank
you for the question wonderful wonderful
question VAR over to you and this looks
like the dioc game
yes absolutely we have some development
here I was looking at this and I think
an Apple has some chances guys in this
game to try to win he's got a nice time
Advantage as well once again we see deck
behind on the clock and last year also
when he was playing this event he was
getting to a lot of the time trouble
positions but he was managing them and
there is a chance here for Napa I will
show you why here so he played the move
B6 here there was an interesting moment
here he could also play the move Rook D7
here
and from the first plant it seems like
wait a minute I can just take the pawn
on A7 but this move actually just loses
if you take on a seven it's just Knight
H4 and the game is over you don't have a
good way now to defend the G2 Pawn
because now if you allow the Knight
takes F3 I will damage the structure and
uh if you play Bishop G4 for example
Queen comes to E4 threading mate on G2
and we know as soon as you play the move
F3 you're just gonna get mated after the
move Queen C2 now G2 again cannot be
protected if you play the move Rook F2
Rook D1 comes in so this was a another
opportunity for nepo to play this move
but he didn't he didn't play that he
played uh the move B6
yeah and now I think he is there can
take actually Queen takes A7 this is G5
here this was the line that uh
absolutely you guys looked at this
there's a G5 here there is also a move
Knight H4 here immediately as well so
both of these moves possible let's take
a look at some of the lines now because
uh they're critical so you can start
with the move G5 they're both equally
good here so perhaps let's go with
Knight H4 first it's very concrete now
you you're threatening to take
um on F3 the bishop so in any of these
lines you cannot allow the move Knight
takes F3 gtx50 because H3 will be
hanging so here actually is the only
move yes sir you'll move Bishop B7 is
absolutely only move here because if you
play Bishop C6 you're just simply losing
after exactly Rook takes C6
and now not not taking the pawn on C4
actually this move Queen E4 now
threatening made on G2 you have to play
F3 now we see the same idea as soon as
the F3 move is played and the second
rank is weakened we play Queen C2 13
made on G2 and Rook F2 doesn't really
help because we have the move Rook takes
D1 check if you blockade with the real
queen G2 mate and if you go to H2 simply
Queen takes F2 wins so after this move
Queen A7 Knight H4 you really have to
find this move Bishop B7
uh which is not that easy I think to
spot and now Rook C5 comes in
what you wanted to play
okay the chess engine is playing our
moves
yeah I think there's some chances here
for Nepal definitely and uh the ACT has
got about 20 25 minutes left and uh
still complicated position 26 minutes we
see on the on the screen against 58 and
Nepal is a very fast player and when he
when he has the initiative uh he plays I
think really well
thank you of our and we have some tweets
uh coming in stump the Masters what do
you got for us uh first one
from Aiden power on YouTube would the
commentators wear clothes designed by
alireza yes absolutely absolutely we are
all about fashion a hundred percent
absolutely alireza you've got two
customers three customers already uh
agreed and I think we'll get Christian
too yes yeah so our customers four
customers yeah yeah when we interview
alireza I think Christian should ask a
little bit more about his fashion what
he's been doing exactly several months
and I'm very curious to know yeah how
did the commentators get some swag
that's what we're talking about another
tweet coming in the door
here we go from Tetris crap now that's a
game I used to love
do you think thing feels pressure to
perform well here or do you think he's
just happy to be world champion and this
doesn't matter much to him I absolutely
think he feels uh responsible now that
he is the world chess champion his life
has changed enormously forever forever
end of story and that he takes this new
position very responsible he thinks that
he's an ambassador of Chess which is so
which he is and so he has to represent
and he does represent the Chess World he
is the as world champion he is the
leader he will be the trendsetter he
will be the ones who like Magnus you're
not supposed to make short draws but
he's going to be the one who's going to
lead us into a new era and I think he's
going to inspire China frequently I mean
the ladies have already done their part
and now uh dingler and so the answer to
question is a big yes he feels very very
responsible one more tweet and we'll get
back to the games this one is from at
eel or oh my God
the question is when is the next World
Bach house Chess Championship and will
yester participate yes yes yes yes yes
um uh all we're looking for is actually
we've got some sponsors here
all we're looking for is First Bank
to open up their accounts with uh the
flowers JC flowers and they you know the
first 10 million dollar bug house uh
competition and Bug House for those of
you may not be familiar with it also
called Siamese chess in the Northwest
you play with a partner
so two players are playing I'll play
wide uh we'll play Black by partner will
play Black and whenever I capture I get
to give you the material and you get the
Checkmate or use your pieces on my board
exactly and uh together we're playing as
a team and it's very very popular with
Junior players most especially but it's
also popular with some of the top
Grandmasters in the world including
Lavon and Rooney I was just going to say
that yeah no I was in Dusseldorf in
February where they actually had a bug
house tournament that featured a lot of
top players and the winner funnily
enough was uh what if Rosenstein and
Lavon who were teammates and the the I
it sounds weird but the sponsor the
tournament working with Lavon one won
the competition and it was sort of like
um
Adam's really really really good and
they were deserving winners I do hope
that they have a professional
competition in the future the buckout I
think so I think it's coming now is it I
have heard groomers I would be elated
and by the way just getting an Insight
that uh Richard Rapport and Duda seemed
to that was the Bishops of opposite
color seem to be going towards a draw
yeah and that was Bishop Texas very even
very even opposite color Bishops Rock
and game
yeah I didn't see how either of them
could play for a win exactly let
uh VAR what do you have for us
yeah we have some development in the
future game uh and looks like he's
actually getting some chances against
Anish giri here let's take a look uh
guys and uh so we we looked at it after
the move A4 and uh after capture on a
four Rook takes A4 now 96 was played I
really like this move because Knight on
C4 actually looks really nice but it's
not really doing much and also black
hitting the Rook so there is really no
pressure on C3 and putting the Knight on
D6 is very well placed now you have some
options to play Knight E4 but most
importantly now you're also putting
pressure on C3 and here Anish had to
actually find a way to make a draw
already because uh there is some risks
actually involving with the C3 Pawn it's
really a backward Pawn if we compare
right now the pawn on B7 is actually
very well protected but the panel C3 is
weak and there was a way here that he
could have maybe tried to force a draw
here with the move Knight C5 and let's
say if B6 is played he plays Knight
takes E6 and again we see that idea with
the weak Square on G6 now after F takes
E6 we have Queen 2 G6 check King h8 and
here you really have to go for the
Perpetual because if you try to play for
a win uh with Rook A7
um there is this Rook C7 move and you
still have the draw here but you have to
repeat now because otherwise after Rook
F7 you might not have that chance here
so this was a very important moment that
he had to play the move Knight C5 he
didn't do that and he played uh Rook B4
which is a little bit awkward now and
there is a pressure on C3 and here we
have Rook C6 very logical move now he
wants to play Queen C7 and now bring the
Rook to C8 and targeting the C3 pawn and
now Knight F4 is played he's hoping to
create some counter play now on H5 but
after Queen C7 I really like Black's
position it's very clear what black
wants to do here wants to put a lot of
pressure on C3 and I think alireza is
taking over the game and uh he's
pressuring now so Anish needs to be
careful here to try to generate some
Contra play otherwise he will have to
put the Knight on E2 and try to do a
very passive defense uh with the C3 Pawn
boy I find that's to be so country
trillion to my way of thinking I see
these double pawns on the king side I'm
carrying you know a lot of scars from
having such a compromised King do you
think alirezia wants to recover from
yesterday was it of course he does sure
what do you think his confidence yeah a
little bit shaken I would say uh not so
easy I wanted to jump into the game of
our tournament a leader uh Wesley so
because uh remarkably to me this was
like the moment for a kiss
when we left it we'd seen the move Queen
B6 Queen B3 castles and I said I want to
emphasize this one of the things you
don't want to do is white you don't want
to help me get a superior pun structure
by capturing and you said yeah but
there's some weak dark swears and maybe
you do want to trade and he did and I'm
like kind of stunned by that castles
Bishop A6 now again my French defense
training my Karo Khan tells me that this
is just good for black you're a loving
black sponsors I love it yeah I mean I I
grew up with this and also the idea that
I've got this half open a file now it's
not like I'm going to play Rook takes A2
I grant you that's not necessary but
just the fact that I could maybe use the
fourth rank or even the fifth rank gosh
knows what I I could use uh yeah I have
the more
flexible for sure yeah I think at this
point MBL realizes that he didn't get
any advantage out of the Oklahoma and
it's trying to exchange pieces and maybe
try to head to a draw and he did he he
goes for that very concretely with the
move E5 and for Wesley I mean two black
pieces and he didn't have a single
problem exactly in this particular case
we talk about the poorly placed Knight
on G7 so if you jump to F5 what what is
White's whole idea well White's idea is
get rid of this bishop that is kind of
not in the game but give ourselves an
opportunity to get an outpost in the
middle of the board yes you two that is
to say black has a Outpost a lot about
C4 e for all of these outposts so that
uh I do think even though you get that
white gives up the F5 square with the
move E5 I think this is a very uh well
timed move now the question is
can I play
no it's weird right can I play Knight H5
I had H5 because what I would really
like you to do is do me the favor of
trading and you know if I simply play G3
yeah I was kind of thinking that I might
probably yeah can I
exploit the the
to take advantage of it no so E5 we'll
probably see Knight F5 since very far uh
my feeling is I like black but I can't
prove it
absolutely yes sir I'm also you know
French French defense player for
lifelong when I saw that movie Space six
I was very happy to see to get rid of
the bad Bishop yeah and black is
actually slightly better here but he has
to find the next move is very important
move here is actually Bishop C5 check
first very nice avoiding avoiding the
trait of the Bishops or at least you're
gonna trade the Bishops in a better
terms here so I will show you some of
the lines now please Bishop C5 the main
point of this move is now you you can
take on uh E5 next so for example if you
play King H1 that's actually a really
bad move now because after F takes E5
Pawn takes C5 and if you guys remember
we were talking about this Knight
finally getting into F5 and this is a
perfect moment now to put the Knight on
F5 now put pressure on the bishop and
black is actually much much better here
Bishop F2 you can even just simply Play
Bishop E7 and it's it's pretty clear
that black is doing really well there is
an open a file pressure on A2 sometimes
also the E5 Pawn is isolated so even if
you play G4 I can Retreat Knight H6 then
put the Knight on F7 putting pressure on
E5 so when Bishop C5 is actually played
you you need to play
um you need to play Bishop F2 here so
this is very important for for white
instead of King H1 you need the small
Bishop F2 okay black is still a little
bit better here there are two different
ways you can continue here if you go
Bishop E7 then there's a bishop H4 again
so you probably just want to take it F
takes E5 and now Bishop takes C5 B takes
C5 and now you take back only five and
now in this case actually you can try to
keep the Rooks on the board you can play
The Rook f8 or Rook B8 and now you have
both open files now targeting the A2 and
B2 pawn and there is some pressure here
it's a very small Advantage here for
black in this position and Ninth will
come to F5 as well
no I mean that once you see it that move
Bishop C5 that makes all the difference
in the world here we stand as we take
our break we only have one result one
result only one draw yeah in the game
ding versus Carolina which was going to
be one of our Marquee games as is the
mvl Wesley so and we're gonna see you on
the other side of the break
thank you
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 students
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
over the roughly one and a half
Millennium of its existence chess has
been known as a tool of military
strategy a metaphor for human affairs
[Music]
thank you
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone we have one result
so far I think we ran versus Carolina in
fact just as you were speaking those
words the second draw has taken place as
mvl and Wesley so another of our Marquee
matchups has surprisingly even
shockingly a repetition has taken place
I like Wesley's position when we went on
break he didn't think it was that much
he did find that all important move
Bishop C5 check
and after Bishop F2 Wesley wasn't
satisfied with what we thought was an
advantageous position by capturing and
playing the move Rook B8 what he did
that is to say Wesley in this position
he went back with the bishop well
holding his breath mvl said okay can I
please go home a little bit ashamed and
embarrassed I would be happy to make a
draw with white I think I'm worse and
that is actually what happened I think
Wesley underestimated his position
maybe but I don't think his Advantage
was that big well let's have a quick
look Bishop Jack Bishop F2 saving his
energies for the white games you know
hey look any time I got an advantage I'm
not saving my energy I'm putting
everything I got into trying to win the
game I'm taking on E5 one thing I don't
think you want to do is have anything to
do with positions where you know weird
things might happen after Rook takes F2
so I do think you're capturing on C5
and uh well
let's ask mvl as uh Christian is with
him in Bucharest
Maxim Yasser and Nazi are asking did you
feel like perhaps Wesley underestimated
his position at the end was he perhaps
better did you feel any pressure coming
from him
um yeah I must admit I was not
completely happy with the way I handled
my opening stage
so um
so I played this F4 bit out of necessity
because I don't want to allow e596.
Let's uh talk about the position in fact
you started off with the London how did
I mean this must be a trend coming from
the world championship match is that the
case uh technically I even played it one
day before
before yeah exactly yeah so but yeah of
course like
we know those ideas but I mean if we
should credit anyone for you know making
use of London Trend it's Magnus
obviously let's talk about it so Knight
to H5 Bishop G5 yeah this came as a
surprise of course
like there's this position in the slab
but I play Knight D2 so I'm on Tempo F
which means after Bishop G5 there's no
more Queen B6
because of 95 I assume 95 for instance
yes and now you have some problems with
the iPhone H5 but so I knew that I mean
Bishop G5 should be the critical try but
after F6 G6 I
couldn't really figure it out did you
feel like he still knew what he's doing
probably and sadly this was one option I
didn't really reconsider before the game
um Bishop Ito was not too happy with my
main point was if Knight G7 then I take
on C5 and adjust to stop it for a second
we just saw Anish and alireza finished
their respective game as well that
finished in a draw Let's uh continue
Maxi yes
take on D4 Knight takes D4 Knight to G7
yeah and here's where I didn't really
enjoy
too much my position because I feel like
for instance if I Castle which should be
the normal way of handling this and ig4
I take with let's say C Pawn I assumed a
knight F5 and
maybe this is not the end of the world
but I felt like if anyone's gonna be
better it's black now this position and
it strikes me a bit as oh it's not a
very conventional position right
as a beginner if you look at it white
has all almost all the pieces developed
Black's Knight is on G7 you moved E6 F6
my pieces are developed but at the same
time I'm slow now in you know getting
them two better squares Plus for Wesley
it's very easy like in to move this
disgusting his Knight can always driven
to F5
which is why I lost time you know to
take to play E4 and then I snap him from
going Knight to F5 and then to play F4
which I felt was not ideal but
but at the same time again if I Castle
E5 I don't really know what to do
maybe here for but
I don't think this was working to be
honest
but maybe you can start with castle and
then later player for because for Queen
Basics check here later play E5 I mean
yeah Castle identify because of yeah
yeah
so anyway I went there for I thought
maybe sometimes I guess or queen size
but after Queen B6 he has a problem is
Queen C2 there's this move which
I mean if Bishop a64 was kind of
okay with that because I want Queen C3
next
but after Castle I just couldn't figure
out what I should do
could I first
right no I I actually considered it here
and it's actually it's an awesome move
yeah yeah
but I thought castleland
like oh Queen C6 now
yeah yeah no no Susan Bishop D7
but yeah
I don't know it felt artificial
and
I was also considering clinifo but even
after Queen bitu
this I was not completely happy with
maybe it's
just winning for white Bloods
that's a wild life yeah but also you
look up what you do probably lose a
night yeah I have to cross us yeah I
mean
but of course you can also go Bishop D7
and I'm not sure what I achieved so I
just thought Queen B3 is a safe option
because now if Queen is three my point
is C4
this is quite nice Queen F4 I think I oh
no of course not
it's intact but if Pawn takes Queen
takes so and after G5 no CD and some
Knight F3 and Well turns out I'm winning
so Queen is in trouble yeah so this was
some kind of Cheap Trick I had but after
Castle it meant that I had to take
and yeah maybe I shouldn't Castle maybe
castling was too too quick but the thing
that I missed is after rookie one
uh it takes
and Knight H5 now yeah and I'm stuck you
cannot go G3 because of G5 yes you lose
the bishop you have to give up the
bishop but that's problematic right so
you know I realized the same time I took
an A6 and played E5 and maybe I'm worse
but
but I don't know I was not too
to another piece in those attacks uh
energy do you feel like he was like
happy with the draw as well yeah I
thought there were two options I'm not
sure that twister was up here with the
draw he felt like he was better I think
uh this was one option I thought but
then I just got Knight F3 and C5 I
go A3 let's say and I mean I I shouldn't
be too much worse it doesn't look like
much
and another which I saw yesterday
mentioning but I thought it was risky
more than anything with this
no I want my business or f8
and
yeah I thought okay like this is maybe
too much so let's say
as we see C4 but
I mean as soon as I have G4 you know
this Knight on G7 is very
it takes a while to get it back in the
game right yeah so I thought I should be
more or less fine even if I lose the B2
Point somewhere I get contemplary on F5
and yeah yeah no it definitely looks
risky for him as well yeah so I thought
I was not too happy with this
um I thought this was a nice try also
but it turns out that I'm fine
engage one and if Knight is free I can
play hook F3 if not I'm probably worse
after Knight G4 but oh that makes a lot
of sense yeah but now 94 you can just
give up the pawn back yeah
this should be good
to E1 have some pressure on the E5
exactly this one looks uh so maybe even
better for you at this point yeah I know
it finished I mean I wouldn't say better
okay I see you know the eval but I
wouldn't have said better
um yes the game finished maybe a bit
untimely but like there were some some
moments how would you assess the start
of the tournament you haven't played
well you actually play some leagues
it was important because I didn't have
any any other classical game before and
that in 2023 and my last tournament you
know was such stronger position was back
in sinfir cup so you know it's good to
get back some
how do you feel about your form right
now coming along nicely yeah it's it's
quite all right
um obviously today was not very
satisfying yesterday was better but you
know those of course it will take you
know one one we know one last two
to make a break they're definitely part
of the game Maxine thank you very much
for joining us we'll see you in the rest
of the rounds thank you
thank you Christian thank you mvl
actually a quick question if I might ask
to mvl first of all greetings from St
Louis mvl you're the defending Champion
but against Wesley so you have a
remarkable plus score how did you do it
and coming into today's game did you
feel like you were going to continue
proceedings
Yasser is saying that against Wesley saw
they checked the graphics before the
game started you have an amazing score I
think six victories and only one loss
did you feel like that's playing a part
in your Encounters in general
putting more pressure on him maybe but
in general it's uh mostly because I
haven't taken as many ways maybe as
other players against Westland because
he's very good at punishing those
and yeah in a few games I got some nice
advantage that I managed to to a lot and
of course I I wanted to to get something
and maybe I took a bit more risk than
usual to you know because I had charging
picture but novelty about the Berlin and
he said one D4 yeah so you know
um it didn't
um guys where I planned but
you know of course uh but I want every
game I have with white generally you
know I
I wouldn't say always but more or less
always want to to get a game and to get
something going so basically the
takeaway from this discussion is that
you should always trust chat GPD
or maybe I shouldn't yes sir do you even
know what Chad GPD is
[Music]
[Laughter]
three draws uh in this the second uh
round and a two games remaining and of
the two games remaining Richard Rapport
dude that was the one game we were
absolutely Stone Cold sure that was
going to end up in a draw and now it's
not so convincing I think Judah actually
uh reached and prematurely played this
move B5 and now he's in a world of hurt
uh we're right here at this position and
frankly if he doesn't play and I think
it's almost critical he plays the move
F5 F4 not an intuitively obvious move
but at this exact moment if you let
white play the move E3
he's going to end end up playing Bishop
E2 and snapping off this Pawn
essentially for free and then once he's
got a queen side structure he'll Target
this Pawn on F7 by bringing the bishop
back to the D5 square and then I've got
a majority
of a four to delay E3 or two get rid of
the double bond
both but definitely to get rid of the
double Pawn but also I would look at it
in another way in the sense that if
white let me play another move uh say H5
which is really a bad move by the way
because you're putting all your pawns on
the color of my Bishop which means thank
you so much you're allowing me to attack
your pawns now a moment ago I played the
move Bishop E2 but what I wanted to
emphasize is that once my Bishop gets on
this diagonal and I'm targeting the F7
Pawn your king is more or less bound to
the defense of the pawn you don't even
want to play the move F6 because then
when my Bishop gets to F7 I can do a
collection right King side pawns will
fall exactly so what you need to do is
first of all get some freedom for your
Bishop
and you want to trade pawns as quickly
as possible if we only lose the B5 pawn
and we could trade off this Pawn for
this pawn and this Pawn for this pawn
and maybe even one more pound than the
draw is just so easily we can even in
the future move our Pawn to F6 so I
think the move F4 is critical VAR and if
you don't play it
it's all white it's play on one goal
absolutely yes sir I think I just saw on
our video that uh Duda is very annoyed
by himself because he just created a lot
of problems for himself and we can see
even right now he's just he just cannot
believe but I want to first show the
mistake I know you discussed is the move
B5 but I'll go back first to point out
what he could have done uh to have
absolutely no problem so this is the
position that they reach first I think
what I would have maybe tried to do in
this position as soon as he played long
Castle immediately I would try to put a
Pawn on B5 yeah just this way I I don't
never have to worry about a move like A4
fixing the pawns and then after that
only you play the move rook hd8 and this
this would have probably the game would
have been drawn by now so Rook HD it
they just trade Rooks so after allowing
the move A4 it's it's still it's still
fine here but all he had to do in this
position instead of playing the B5 move
right away you should just play the move
Rook A5 first and be preparing the move
B5 and after that just simply take back
with the Rook right and again they the
game probably would have been drawn by
now but instead he played the move B5
immediately
allowing
this position and now he probably missed
this move before it is very very strong
uh move and now the pawns are fixed as
we can see here the B7 on the light
score B5 and also the F7 pawn and here
F4 is absolutely necessary you're
absolutely right you have to play this
mode because otherwise in a lot of these
lines you could just slowly be lost if I
put the pawn on F4 myself and Pawn on E3
it's going to be a problem so I can I
can go a little bit deeper and show some
of the ways black can hold but it's not
easy sometimes actually you end up in a
down a two Pawn positions so for example
F4 yep now takes Bishop page four I try
to go really deep to see the the ideas
here it looks like I can just play King
E3 for example right and the next move
you really want to do is to play put the
pawn on F5 now okay and now Bishop B3
for example then you play Bishop F6
putting pressure on C3
you defend it King goes on the Chain now
you gonna need to play this move B6
eventually so you can just play right
away
and now Bishop let's say Bishop D5 right
now you play G5
you're actually giving up the B5 Pawn
here so if takes
you take
Bishop to
C6 now Bishop E5 will come attacking the
pawn and now after actually you play G4
trying to create a counter play here
and if you take on G4 Pawn takes Bishop
takes B5 you play them with G3 and here
even though white is up two pawns you
can't really make a much progress King
will be sitting on D6 you can never
Advance the E Pawn and if you try to
bring the king to B5 I can put the
bishop which by four Bishop B3 and block
a the position so you will be able to
hold this position but again you're
gonna have to be in a position where
you're probably down two pounds and just
try to set up Fortress wow nice thank
you uh for uh two pawns down and that
looked like it uh it's a drawer because
the pawns are too close to each other
right exactly if they're separated more
than three throws I think
I mean you know just because I read the
offer Box series of End Game books
doesn't mean like I know I can quote the
chapter so use it to forget when you
don't see it in practice yeah exactly
yeah uh turning our attention to the
other remaining game our Challenger uh
nepo uh he had sacrificed well he had
been the recipient of an exchange
sacrifice long long long time ago
and I want to say G5 yes I wanted to say
that I see three results this is a game
that really it could turn on a dime uh
what we really desperately want as white
is to establish our Bishop on C6 where
it's protecting the G2 Pawn is
protecting B5 but we know that the
moment Rook takes C6 is played it's
going to be check made on the king side
so you can't put the bishop on C6 the
last move was actually Queen A6 Rook C2
Queen A6 and we're up to date with this
player by with the play by the way G5
so after the move Queen A6
where how you need a concrete follow-up
too though right I do I think it has to
be H5 H5 let's do it not G4
I'm going to prepare it with H5
well you you're preparing the move G 5
G4 weighted move because what is white
going to do yes okay so you you want to
play H5 so you're going to play G4 so
that you give yourself the option
recapturing with a Pawn on the other
hand when you play G5 and G4 I figure
you're trying to blow up
the king side the G2 Pawn is quite well
protected okay with the bishop so if I
manage to open up age file yeah that
will be a Checkmate okay for sure so I'm
gonna play Bishop uh to G3 you know to
you know uh
salute the fact that you're gonna kill
me yeah uh maybe Knight F5 back okay and
once again I'm gonna play for one of
those cocoon positions that I had
mentioned a moment ago but I think I'm
throwing in H4 and then G4 as well okay
so let's see it so I go King
H1 so that Queen takes E3 will not come
with the check right
so did you suggest I go G4 first H4
how many good options all right it's all
you it's on you it's on you I'm gonna
try G4 okay so G4 my first reaction is I
want to keep things closed on the king
side for just the just uh is that doable
what if I play Queen F6 so you are gonna
go for
my H Pawn right I'm gonna go for your B6
bomb
maybe Rook D2
well no threats but don't fail me now
guys but I do see a check
okay
I didn't want I didn't I didn't want you
to go to G7 so but I think even going to
H7 still unpleasant
nice yeah Rook D2 was definitely not a
good move okay okay so yeah so
um
did he play F4
no he didn't yes sir he didn't he didn't
play the move F4 it's a little bit
surprising because you you once you
start realizing you're in trouble you
wanted you want to call for some Contra
place with this F formal so it was very
important to play this move do that took
his time as you can see he's got only
nine minutes left on a clock right now
and he didn't play the move F4 so he
played G5 and now I think he's in very
very serious trouble I think uh uh
report has some good winning chances now
let's take a look now what he can do so
he played uh the both G5 again he had to
play the move F4 and now report played
the move F4 it's it's a very important
move here again you want to fix opponent
pawns on the light squares now we have
another Pawn on F5 that is fixed so it
takes
GTX F6 or GTX F4 and now F5 Pawn is weak
and as you can see the evaluation is
already plus two here so it's a two Pawn
advantage that means you're gonna get in
end up in a position where you're going
to be down two pounds here and uh let's
look at some of the lines here let's say
Bishop H4 if you try to activate the
bishop you just play the move E3 now you
protect all your pawns now you want to
play Bishop E2 here pick up the B5 Pawn
if you try to defend with the King let's
say you play King D6
Bishop gozoni 2 attacking the pawn on B5
he tried to defend it this way and now I
can try to attack F7
for example with Bishop page five is a
good move
now if you play F6
Bishop G6 and pick up the pawn right you
you want to provoke the move F6 here
because later on when you pick up the F5
you'll have entry squares for your king
to get into like from G6 and E6 that's
the reason it's it's better to play the
move Bishop H5 first instead of just
directly trying to come here and pick up
the pawn
so so you you're going to be losing
couple of Pawns here probably two pawns
until maybe some chances still for uh
for uh for a draw but it's it's a very
very difficult defense ahead for Duda
here
well for me I I gotta say I find it
remarkable we're talking about a bishops
of opposite color position
White's not even a pawn up at the moment
right and we can yeah it's even Steven
but we can see that
it's close to Lost dude I look like and
it's such a rare case of Bishops of
opposite color where I could say dude
you're busted I feel for him right now
as as players we know how that feels yes
he just a couple moves ago he could have
fixed the draw exactly and now he has to
sit and suffer in this end game for many
many moves right right just you know he
kind of like took his eye off the ball
with that early B5 and he was just
thinking oh we're heading towards a draw
but it was that move
b2b4 that rocked his world because if
the funny part we were talking about F4
let me just emphasize how important this
recapture was maybe when he got here
Duda was expecting King takes
and then the whole difference is that
once I play B4 I've got nothing to worry
about because this two pawns are equally
matched by this single Pawn by being
able to recapture with the bishop and
then captures it's like wait a minute
it's just it's it's just such a narrow
path the moment I play B4 then it
becomes crystal clear the B Pawn on B7
the B Pawn on B5 are both very
vulnerable the F7 and why did I agree to
this and Richard must have seen it and
played Bishop D1 the sneaky movement
not so innocent at all I did see he
played before very quickly yes so that
he was hoping for this position exactly
securing a weakness that he can nibble
upon and we have some uh tweets from the
social media questions for ourselves or
you you ready I am all right let's do it
this one is from chess
chirper I like that all right the
question is where is the best prettiest
coolest venue or area you have played or
whereas the worst place you have to play
okay uh there's been some really really
cool venues I mean I don't know if
you've ever been to the United Arab
Emirates go to the Dubai chess club in
the Sharjah chess clubs they're just
fabulous as is St Louis chess club I
think some of the Olympic places I've
played have been really really nice but
I remember playing in convention centers
in Belgrade and the Hall of columns
where they played this the uh
the world championship matches in the
Hall of columns were really fantastic
prestigious players places I played in
basements
of uh churches and and what have you so
I've had
some bad venues yeah yeah some bad
venues you I will as soon as I was
reading the question the answer came to
mind instantly right the best venue I've
played in was the World Chess Hall of
Fame just two months ago American Cup
just planning a museum you felt good it
felt amazing right yes and I know in
Paris they were playing in an art museum
that was really really you had that
feeling like you're in this Museum of
Art and this nice VAR jump right in your
best and worst venues uh my favorite
venue uh probably definitely is a Saint
Louis Chestnut where I played many many
U.S championships and I always play you
know try to play my best chess there
also I remember once I played the
Continental championship in Argentina
that was a very nice venue we had uh
really enjoyed playing here in St Louis
where I live and I don't have to to
travel right one other uh friends of
mine
um
Mark stephrack Leo stefrak uh the
brothers were deaf and they said yes sir
could you play
as simultaneous for the Washington State
deaf Association I said with pleasure
where are we going to play and it was
the Swedish Convention Center
it's one of those big big rooms where
you could you had a wall divider
where you could just pull it's like a
plastic curtain that kind of like
unfolds and you just divide the room I'm
playing this simultaneous against the
Washington deaf Association members and
one of the I was reading the rules and
one of the participants said miss you
know I said don't make a move when I'm
not in front of you and the fellow asked
me well how will I know when you're in
front of me
and he was deaf blind and mute
so I said I will kick you he said well
that will be fine you know he did the
signing
well anyway I can't believe this is like
it's unbelievable
but on the other side of the wall was
amateur bagpipe night
it's like what hello I mean bagpipes
when they're played professionally
five minutes is plenty when it's amateur
bagpipe night well I gotta tell you
within an hour my head was like Bang
Bang
so during the symbol I stopped and I
said could somebody please get those
guys to shut up
everybody in the venue that I was
playing in was deaf because everybody
who could hear it already left a long
time ago and like that was the worst
menu ever ever you know playing the deaf
Association think of a worse venue I
think I've been very lucky to play in
such good environments
boy you got to get out more yeah
what's happening in diox game uh over to
you well let's take a look guys so one
thing it's clear he's in serious time
trouble here he's got two minutes with
more than 10 moves to go and I think
Nepal has some real chances here but
let's take a look at the position
position is still fine for him perhaps
he maybe made some innocuous this here
when we were analyzing Nepal played a
little bit surprising move but I think
it's a good psychological moment because
definitely this move was probably not
expected I know you guys were looking at
the movie H5 which is very interesting
move and here E4 would have been the
best option to try to maybe secure the
device where for the for the bishop but
he actually played this unexpected move
King G7
and this is I guess for some of the some
point you know if there are checks on
the background the king will be uh safe
on G7 and now B4 played perhaps not the
best move the idea is just to try to
bring the queen to A1 with the check he
he had some options here Queen A2 was
the best move here to try to pin The
Rook here and white is doing uh fine
here after this book but he did spend
some time after King G7 he spent about a
couple of minutes and he now has only
four minutes so he played B4 and now
Nepal played Rook C2 and Rook is
actually very strong on a second round
possibility of the other Rook now coming
in on D2 as well and again you you don't
have that much time here so you play
Queen A1 check and now F6 blocking is
very safe and secure now and uh yeah now
we see the ark is actually uh less than
one minute on the clock still very
complicated position and uh he's
definitely on the back foot I think a
really good chances I see here for black
with Rook d82 coming up and possibly
some tactics at some point well this is
nepos forte is getting his opponent in
the time trouble and pushing the
envelope and putting the pressure on his
opponent even without time trouble I
think black has a very good initiative
and good chances to win exactly but
given DX time right now with 20 seconds
on the clock yeah I'd be shocked if he
manages to hold it save this yeah yeah I
mean he'll be a real challenge what is
what are the clock times again and the
number uh Duke has 10 seconds he just
happened exactly 40 seconds right he
just completed his story at move guys so
he still has 10 more moves to go and
he's getting up from the board oh he's
nervous Apple has 35 minutes so I got
this other really kind of funny story I
think
a lot of players over the years have
played simultaneous yes games that was
how a lot of Grandmasters earned a
little extra money was to play 30
players at once sometimes you don't have
enough players to play against you only
have say 10 opponents in which case to
handicap the grand Mastery of them
further you would play blindfold
so this one is from blastomel horde
Grandmaster from the Czech Republic you
know he's in Germany and he's in this
room where he doesn't have sight of the
board and there's a runner coming in and
saying I'm board one you got this on
board two you got this movement board
two you got this movement and so on so
there's blastemolyuna having his coffee
in a separate room whereas in the club
everybody's you know at the board you
know looking at this in this very
well-dressed woman came in and was
staring at blastemol and last and we'll
poured himself some coffee she got up
he's not blind he's not blind she ran
out of the room he's not blind
blindfolds something about that just I
just cracks me up every time I I think
about it uh jumping uh to the game of
Duda for a second he's put his Bishop on
F2 that doesn't help his case at all
there's no way he's going to be losing
pawns from here every 10 moves another
Palm is going to disappear from the
boardvar absolutely yeah sir he's going
to lose the B5 Pawn now and most likely
he's going to drop one of the F pawns
and then he's you know his best hope is
to come up with some kind of defensive
mechanism here to try to defend this
this end game but it's going to be very
difficult so let's take a look what
perhaps he's trying to do now so he
brought the bishop to F2 now and uh I
would play the move E3 here just to make
sure to close down the bishop if let's
say Bishop G1 just put the pawn on H3
right and then take combify but I guess
he didn't like the move HD ah here
actually we have
King E2 uh oh and we can try to trap the
bishop oh that's nasty
yeah black needs a Tempo if the pawn was
on H5 that would be fine yes right H4
Bishop G3 it looks like yeah you're
gonna have to come back to immediately
yeah immediately and now Bishop takes B5
let's see how white will try to win the
second Pawn here because uh let's say B6
is played right
uh one of the options is to play let's
say Bishop A6 now to play Bishop two C8
and now King D7
all right I see the engine wants you to
play Bishop Bishop F1 yeah now the point
is to try to put a bishop on H3 right if
let's say you play uh the the bishop
move now Bishop will go to H3 attacking
the pawn on F5 and if you play King E6
now then after E4 you will be losing the
second Pawn that's easy yeah so when
that happens the bishop F1 you have to
play the move King E7 or King E6
immediately so with Bishop H3 is played
you will have to play the move King F6
but here your Bishop's so messed up
maybe I can just make a past Pawn I
think yeah this is the idea he will try
to uh play King D3 and perhaps C4 C5 or
even King C4 uh maybe King C4 and King
B5 as well easy uh going back to the
game of diach for a moment because it's
all about the time trouble let's keep an
eye on this one king H1 was played how
do you feel about them apples VAR is
there a way that we can crack open the
king side uh I think your idea that you
were looking at earlier with H5 looks
very interesting just trying to create
more attacking chances perhaps to play
the move G4 and then open up the H file
so I think in time pressure with 40
seconds on the clock would be very
unpleasant to face the move H5 here
let's take a look at some of the lines
after that so let's say page five and
you see a concrete idea G4 is coming and
Rook h8 possibilities out there as well
um
the best move is either to play Bishop
C6 or E4 here so let's say you play
Bishop two
C6 now you can play the move Rook A2 the
point of this one is to attack the queen
and also take away the queen A7 move
completely and now Queen to C1 okay and
now we get I would actually play this
move there there are other moves as well
but now you have two Rooks uh on the
second round it's incredible that even
with this the evaluation is very very
small here it just shows how solid the
White's position is here still but here
you have to play the only move now E4
already but it looks devastating you're
doubled on the set and it's it's a very
minor Advantage for what for for black
but that's remarkable yes uh and now if
you just take on F2
wow this incredible now oh Bishop D5 now
uh now we see the point of the move E4
because now you're attacking the queen
and the Rook on A2 again very very
difficult I think to navigate through
these lines in a time pressure but the
move E4 is is absolutely necessary to
give yourself this option of Bishop D5
so we can play now Rook a
C2 attacking the queen queen goes to A1
and uh
it's possible now to take on C6 here
very very complicated lines here a lot
of a lot of possibilities but it looks
like white is still holding the
evaluation is very small but I I think
it'll be incredibly hard for Derek to
navigate through these complications
okay on the board the position that you
have on the board
anytime we were playing the bishop C6
move in the past you were capturing on
C6 and playing Queen E4 and mating me on
G2 why isn't that the case now in this
position yeah so let's take a look here
so if we take now uh 66 right Pawn takes
C6 you were meaning me so often yeah I
mean you hit me yeah but now I think
that that's where we see the point of
this move King H1 yeah sorry it gives
you an option actually to play Rook G1
okay go ahead it's very passive but uh
still it's like holding the position for
now Rook takes F2 682 Queen A7 check
okay King G6
and now you've got the same skeptical
voice
it's yeah it's incredible Rook takes G2
and it's good you don't have anything
more than you have to go to
age six here because if you go to F5 I
have Queen two uh H7 check chess is not
fair
and now Queen h8 wow somehow white is
holding this position remarkable that
move King H1 uh
wow it showed uh you do also have the F3
move there too guys so Rook G1 it's not
the only move you still can play
actually F3 in this position so yes and
uh
well now you're just being insulting
that's exactly yeah
Queen takes C6 and again now some Contra
plays coming with Queen A7 check
if you go to G you want to keep the Rook
on it you can play Rook B7 yeah with a
small Advantage but if you go to G6 now
then again Queen to B8 creating uh
chances now with the queen G8 check so
this idea to bring the queen all the way
to the eighth Rank and give checks is is
the way
key defensive idea
okay and the current position in the
current times Nashi what's going on
right we have King H1 on the board okay
and uh Diaz has 40 seconds 40 seconds
yeah Ian is taking his time because he
had 35 minutes I think last time we
checked so he's been thinking for about
eight minutes move 30 so he still has uh
so diac is going to be playing on
increments and getting the 30 second
increment each time it might not survive
for 10 moves though with 40 seconds
exactly but one of the things that I
like to do whenever my opponent is in
time trouble one of the things I start
looking for is non-forcing moves that
are really good right I mean if the
forcing moves are good plan of course of
course but if you don't have a way of
going talk talk and wins then when your
opponent's in time travel you want to
give them a little rope
he's nervous already maybe you'll see
ghosts right that's right like move H5
yeah it's one of those waiting moves
maybe you don't get Perpetual check
because your bond happens to be on H5
and otherwise yeah I I'm warming up to
that move specifically here uh but I
gotta tell you I mean as far white here
is very difficult
true true uh but I think I I mean he
played Rook D2 of course yeah how do you
not play rookie too responded
immediately with Bishop G3 which right
this is the Cocoon what about nine to
five now right this is what we were
saying uh kind of as a cocoon let's say
I go just now the second round oh no I
have to keep the difference
I have to keep my Rook protected
okay now I'll play Bishop C6 this is
what I was saying that
um wait there's there's no Checkmate
here go Checkmate not that I can see not
yet yeah that uh my Bishop on C6 will be
a real
roof late night of five by the way it's
on the board already okay and Nick has
uh about 50 seconds now to because he
played his last two moves quickly got
that extra 30 second bonus it adds up
and uh
as far as we as we keep our eye on this
game that's in time trouble
Richard's making progress
uh yes yes sir actually I've I've been
told by my friend adios who's working in
a truck that with a stronger engine this
position is actually just winning it's
like plus seven this end game
so it's and perhaps this last move H5
didn't really help it's uh you know
maybe you know made it more more
difficult Black's defense but let's take
a look why
so H5 is played now King E2
attacking the bishop right Bishop has to
go back now only move to H4 okay and now
we take the pawn on B5
yep so let's say B6 okay
Bishop C4
now King goes to F6
and now we try to
I guess we can try to bring the king now
King D2
and again I think the bishop is going to
end up on H3 yes sir the line that we
looked at it earlier and this bishop is
misplaced here on H4 so let's say King
E7 yep ah now H Pawn is hanging it's
gone yeah so yeah you have to go King G6
bar go King G6
yeah I get okay King F6 King D2 King G6
King G6 yeah in that position so let's
see
here King G6 yeah
um
so we don't lose the H5 H5 Pawn yes
again it's it's not uh very clear the
plan but eventually I think white will
make progress here Bishop Bishop goes
two
e F1 we have Bishop H3 ideas
so let's let's see we have some moves
now in this game so we have
Bishop page four Bishop takes B5 Duda
must just be cursing himself I mean just
that he's in this position totally
suffering when he had
nobody to blame by it himself he just uh
walked into a very very very worst
feeling is that he's not also 100 sure
this is lost there's still a hope that
he can hold this yeah but you into it
that you may be you know already on you
know the edge I definitely don't want to
be in his situation no you don't but he
still thinks maybe I can still hold this
so he's still trying
one minute on the clock by the way he's
also in time trouble but the action is
on the other table uh as Challenger uh
Jan nepo has just played the move Knight
and we do have Bishop C6 on the board
and dayak is saying okay go ahead
obliterate my king side do the worst
that you can
uh to me and don't don't think for a
moment that I'm hanging my Pawn on E3
because I have a nasty nasty surprise F6
is actually hanging so after this move
Bishop C6 a well-timed move uh VAR is
there a way that black can
cause injury
yes I think yesterday actually made some
mistakes now and now I think nepo is got
very very good winning chances here we
can take a look at some of the lines now
so um it started right here King H1 was
a good defensive move but after Rook dd2
it just looks the pressure is uh too
much here the pressure on F2 so he
decided to play he had to play the move
Queen A7 this is his best move here to
try to create Contra play or to play the
move E4 we went over this line if Rook
takes F2 Bishop D5 yeah he has a bishop
D5 idea so after exchanging the Rooks
Bishop D5 but instead he played the move
Bishop G3 here
and now Knight F5 comes in with the
tempo now right and threatening to take
on GTA now if you play for example
Bishop H2 then just simply Rook takes F2
you're losing the F2 Pawn right he did
Play Bishop C6 so he did Play Bishop C6
trying to secure the bishop but now uh
block can start with the move Rook A2
okay to make sure the Rook doesn't get
uh the queen doesn't get active on an a
file and you can play Queen
um on the board by the way Queen C3
let's say and now he had played Queen B1
bar Queen B1 okay so we have Queen B1
played already and now you can take on
G3 first do it and
why not immediately age five or age five
that was another option here
and just the fact that you're doubled
along this second rank it makes all the
difference in the world huh yeah
absolutely white doesn't have any any
active moves here and uh
uh you can play Queen E4 but I think
you're probably going to be losing that
end game yes if you play H4 for example
it's another alternative here then you
can even play the move G-Force
and your E3 Pawn is hanging as well in
some of these lines
this is a really sad position for what
truly
yeah let's take a look if he plays this
move as Nazi suggested the H5 move yeah
now again very very difficult position
because the threat of H4 is coming and
that's exactly what it is you just
played H5 and now threatening to play H4
attacking the bishop
and the bishop goes back then simply
take on F2 right yes that's one of those
moves H5 uh that you want to just you
know keep the pressure don't trade
pieces make your opponent you know come
up with something
whenever he wants exactly The Bishop's
not going anywhere yeah the bishop is
Tethered to the F2 Pawn
Yeah white has to play H4 here or queen
E1
quiniforce okay okay
and he played Queen E4
and he's going into that end game that I
think we all despise yeah Queen takes E4
and Knight takes G3 that's just an
exchange and Rook picks up all kinds of
Pawns yeah we were talking about dude as
pawns being vulnerable after this move
Queen E4 is like the E3 Pawn as well as
the B4 Pawn is vulnerable so something
like rookie two and Rook B2 are on
Black's agenda and these pawns will fall
no fortresses for white yeah one after
the other yes exactly no fortresses
did you like that comment by the way by
Magnus Carlson he doesn't I don't
believe in fortresses that was cute I I
thought that was uh I liked his comment
but I don't agree with it no of course
not because there are fortresses that do
work and he Magnus actually I think it
was in his match with cram um not
kramnik but Sergey
kariakin where he ended up making The
Fortress in one particular game or it
was the other way around karyakin he was
good at defending yeah
yeah uh this ending uh evaluation uh VAR
looks really really high for
um uh for Yan after Queen E4 Queen takes
E4 what's the valuation yeah evaluation
is actually just winning yeah just
winning it's about plus five oh my gosh
that's huge so and he's gonna go for it
he just took only four yep and we're
gonna see Knight takes G3 next and uh
then actually after I takes G3 there is
an interesting line here you have this
move F5 now
right right here wow yes Queen takes E4
Bishop takes E4 Knight takes G3 with a
check and F5 now why can't I take well
if you take with a rook you might get
made it on the background I see I don't
have all right if I play G4 that'll be
H4 right jack
and oopsie Daisy whether you take or not
it doesn't matter but the point is G4
doesn't give you that uh but if you took
with the bishop wait no then G2 G3
after H4 oh excuse me it's probably
still amazing Rook takes F5
uh check and check
or check a mate threat G4 and use
partnership oh then I check and pick up
your picture G2 and will is the bishop
yeah
I can't go can I get five pounds
it made it on the first round too yeah
oh my so F5 well that's a visual but
it's
in this game right F5 is just the
probably best move
right but he has plenty of other options
right
but you see it and why it ignores it and
goes Bishop C6
well then you just go back to uh I guess
picking off pawns uh Rook F2
and or Rook E2 I am assuming Rook takes
F5 is always going to get mated he
played Rook B2 by the way on the board
yeah very hard to play a move like F5
because in your mind's eye
this bond is actually kind of useful you
know and you kind of go okay this Pawn
might not look like much but it is a
pawn and uh dayak is saying okay do your
worst you're welcome to munch this
fellow
I want to munch
this fellow
should black just push I wouldn't push
H4 maybe kid just can king
um
as long can you just exam Bishop before
Chuck and then I have to move again okay
but what you do have is your thought too
before I have G4
you woke up on the right side of that
today look at you sharp as ever G4 I
really like that move because that
really does uh say to the bishop hey you
know you've got to make your your your
choice right now
did Richard make an error yeah he made a
slight inaccuracy here actually uh I
have the position here guys I will show
you and in this position actually it's
very important to keep this E2 Square
for your Bishop so every time opponent
plays Bishop page 4 you have the bishop
b2id and you just simply pick up the
pawn on H5 if you win the pawn on H5
that position will be already completely
winning so he had to just simply take on
B5 this would have been the best option
here because this bishop is actually
sort of trapped here yes sir because you
don't have a way to get back into the
game that easily here right so because
Bishop H4 I have Bishop E2 winning the
H5 pawn and the game so this was very
important to do but instead he played
King E2 King E2
and this is inaccuracy now because now
you don't have this move uh it should be
Bishop E2 anymore so now Bishop goes
back to H4
Bishop takes and now at least the bishop
is back to uh
uh yeah yeah right and that's why when
uh you know after the move H5 that's why
the evaluation was that big because you
know because you don't have a good way
to get the bishop back into the game so
but now since the bishop is back it's
it's around plus two still and we have a
couple of more moves Play Bishop C4
check
King E7
King D3
now H4 makes a big difference and now
Bishop D5 B6 and now he played Bishop G2
in this position the best move actually
in this position is to start with the
move Bishop B7 this would have been an
improvement over Bishop G2 because now
you're threatening to play the move
Bishop C8 and pick up the second Pawn
right so if let's say he tries to play
King D7 this is the important part here
and now we play Bishop to G2 and we are
getting that position with the bishop H3
answer that we had earlier King goes to
E6 the bishop to H3 and with the idea of
E4 and winning the second pawn and uh
with a very good winning chances here
for white from that starting position go
back earlier before the move King E2 I
found myself maybe you too Naji drawn to
the idea right here of playing Bishop E2
provoking the move H4 go ahead and play
the move Bishop E2 for just a second bar
Bishop E2 H4 oh okay let me see if I can
do it on my board just for a moment uh
right right about here instead of
looking I find myself
drawn to this idea Naji I go Bishop E2
gift me the pawn if I take that pawn
it's it's game over yeah because I'm
still gonna take the F Bond and the B
Pawn you have to play H4 I'm going to
play H3 and now Black's Bishop right
exactly isn't that just cute this bishop
is like trapped trap win it but right
you can't go back to the game yeah it
could go to G3 and that's it it's just
like kind of stuck there the problem is
in a lot of those variations where we
were winning the F5 Pawn we were doing
it by Bishop H3 and E4 so we have taken
that away but in any case I I found
myself drawn to the move Bishop E2 for
just a moment and let me update the
board
um
is it winning is it still winning it's
it feels like the answer should be yes
right because Bishop H3 I still do pick
up a second Pawn
right if you go it is winning I got E4
and if you don't play King it's a draw
Blackness to make all the accurate moves
and uh what's the time situation
we have okay Richard has 16 17 minutes
and Duda has two minutes on the clock
will be blitzing making natural looking
moves sure which is not always good
enough in an end game like this exactly
but those two parts should do it I'm uh
turning our attention to uh nepo's uh
position with deak because he has got
this Pawn date yeah he did exactly what
we were thinking uh Bishop F3 played
King H6
G4 H4 sure I'll take over this G3 Square
make sure that I always have a Checkmate
uh on the back rig so I've ever play
Rook H1 Bishop went to C6 King back to
G7 unlike the pawn on F6 well I can also
exchange one pair of rocks because white
okay you'll never be active anymore and
black king will March all the way to the
queen side Center yeah I think it's
there's an inevitability that this Pawn
also gets lost so it's it's going to be
four versus four yeah and White's Bishop
is going to defend a lot of important
pawns but eventually you can see that
Black's King I think I'll engineer a
trade of Rooks and uh Black's King will
March One Day to all the way to G3 I
feel uh
to move 40 but I don't think this game
will last much longer
in short Wesley so will find himself
with company yeah for nepo
should he win this game and we think he
has every reason to expect that he will
win this game this will be a very
important victory for him because he's
looking to rebound and bring some
confidence of course and uh
black Elon is is already boost for your
documents
and as we get ready for a quick break
prep your questions for us as we'll see
you on the other side
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back everyone
uh we have an update yes we did win his
game okay and we had three draws uh as
we went on break break we thought Napa
was going to win there was some
inevitability uh because we could force
a trade of Rooks and then the king would
eventually just come marching gallantly
up the board
extra material as well paid off and it
and nepo uh finds himself tied for first
with uh Wesley so and as we get set up
for a conversation with nepo that leaves
us with one game remaining Richard
Rapport and during our break Vara and I
were discussing
this particular situation pardon me we
were just right here and I was saying to
to VAR I would love to play the move E4
and VAR was pointing out to me that it's
not that easy that after the move Bishop
h
uh six
Bishop takes check Kate D6 if I go after
this one
there is a problem
and this guy I'm losing one of my queen
side pawns and that is one way that
Richard could let the wind slip away
from his grasp so so Richard didn't do
that he ended up playing the move Bishop
F1 and I think not going for that E4 uh
break but in any case it's a big big uh
result before how does pardon me without
pushing E4 how is why it made progress
well I think what white really wants to
do exactly here right now is to put the
bishop on C8 so if I could put the
bishop on C8 that's going to force the
king
back to the F6 Square once you're on the
F6 Square you're not going to be able to
attack C3 which means king B5 and I can
sneak in that way let's ask VAR uh how
close
is Richie to winning the game and has he
blown it or is it still okay
you're you I think you're not miked in
oh sorry okay uh you were just about to
tell us that maybe there was a few
inaccuracies there that was going on
yeah
okay so what VAR was saying is right
more or less this place hold on
where are we it was this move King three
two okay five right
okay uh VAR
apologies I was stealing your thunder uh
go for it how should he win well it's
not so clear yes or how he should win
the position it definitely missed
opportunity there with the King E2 move
but uh I will show you some lines here
but it's not so clear how to win that
second pound because we know in order to
win this position you need to win the
second pawn two extra pawns you will
have some serious winning chance if you
don't win the pawn I don't think you can
win this game so let's take a look at
some of the lines how he can try to make
progress here so Bishop H3 unfortunately
this line for for white king E6 E4
doesn't really work because E4 Bishop
page six you lose the F4 pawn and then
as well the H2 pawn and uh looks like
black is holding now it shows equal at
the moment so we had to try to maneuver
here we can start for example we can
start out with the move Bishop B7 here
right the threat is Bishop C8 now to win
the pawn here and now uh the only move
here is I actually to play King D7 okay
because if you play King E6 then I have
a bishop C8 check forcing the king to F6
and now since the bishop is already
blocked I think we can even play the
move King B5 and try to pick up the I
think that was your idea yeah yeah
absolutely that's uh yeah give seven and
C4
yes and here we went upon so that's why
he has to play King D7 here to prevent
the move Bishop C8 and again you're a
little bit tied up now to the defense of
the C3 Pawn so you don't have any moves
like King B5 at the moment and um if you
play Bishop D5 yeah simply King E7 back
okay
um
perhaps you can try to maneuver the king
one idea I see maybe King B3 he can try
to start with and here block this is the
perfect setup for Blockhead he doesn't
need to change anything the King on D7
is well placed and ambition so he will
basically Play Bishop h8
wow what a waiting move it looks
terrible yeah um and um why can't I play
Bishop D5 let's say you play Bishop D5
King e77 yes and let's get down to
business C4 C4 bring our King to B5 and
play C5
yeah so let's say Bishop G7 okay just
waiting
and if I go C5 and B5 of R if you play
C5 I will capture B5 B5 is an idea
definitely gold play B6 Go baby go bring
us glory and now
some different ways to defend but
probably this F6 is interesting what
free up the king because you don't want
to lose the F7 Pawn King C4 right okay
1886 yeah okay
B6 B6
Bishop f8
how is this not winning I mean yeah
Black's just holding in this very very
accurate and now B7 bc7 now Bishop C6
and King D5 and can I make a a break to
the king side
and now I just I just wait King B8 so
King D5 King E6 King D5 no just King C7
now right
and if King is six then we can maybe
start pushing the C I see
we have such beautiful positional
understanding we deserve we deserve
Victory just because of our
understanding of the position yeah it
could be guys it was crucial that one
moment where he played this move kinky
too we're just keep coming back to that
idea of King E2 where he played because
at that point he could he had a way to
win the second Pawn
uh that was move 30 if I've got it 31
yes King E2 yeah that was where where uh
we had let the bishop get back to uh H4
back into civilization and we could have
just started with Bishop takes B5 yeah
yes in this case he would have won the
second Pawn this is when the evaluation
was really really big and showing a
winning Advantage for white
great and let's just remind everybody
who showed up late shame on you by the
way for showing up late but we do have
one win yes we have three
one win with black Pieces by any
publisher yeah and one game still going
on yeah the two victories that have
occurred so far in the first two rounds
have been by black uh rather remarkable
our congrats to nepo as a really
handsome questions for him uh as he gets
set up but we're thinking the current
was so I'm not sure what you stated
about the the current state of affairs
so is it Holden is it holding well the
evaluation is showing about plus one and
a half but it's not showing a clear way
for why to make progress here so I think
with a very precise play block is
probably holding this position wow
yeah I wouldn't I'd lose the bet I would
I would bet that white could win this
sorry uh yeah during the break uh I
think I was saying that I'm gonna call
this this is going to be a draw uh I
think I don't trust plus 1.5 engine
evaluation here plus one obviously
because white has an extra Pawn right
and that 0.5 shouldn't be enough for
white to win this exactly by the way are
you a big engine fan do you play with
the top engines and no I hate the engine
you hate the engine I hate the engine
it's impressive so much creativity out
of Chess especially the openings right
so I try to not use it as much as I can
but when you play it in a professional
level you can't avoid it of course yeah
you you have to refer to it it's a very
important tool but let's jump to
Bucharest as Christian is with nepo
thank you Yasser we are indeed with the
world championship Challenger yard first
of all commiserations for the match that
was very very difficult but you still
came here and I feel that you came with
great energy do you feel the same
uh I guess it's thank you for
uh for commiserations as you said yeah
uh no not really I guess uh it's
important to to play a bit a bit more
for for a while yeah I think but after
Dubai I went to our show soon enough uh
so I wouldn't say I'm like full of uh
full of energy like motivation and ideas
but I mean okay it's
um it's my job yeah it has to be done
you just have to keep going and that's a
great attitude yeah yeah perhaps let's
talk about the game today because
um with the black pieces it's never easy
to win in this type of events yet you
did so today tell us a bit about the
game
I wouldn't say it was me winning it was
more about
um
I'm not sure what was his particular was
it a blunder or was it like a exchange
sack I mean uh and I was early on in the
opening yeah I guess uh I guess lines
goals like BJ's C3 and then some weird
perpetual
uh but uh yeah Queen C3 yeah I think 97
or something Turkish five
four
uh maybe should be six first okay I I
couldn't recall but there is some some
sort of repetition here very very
artificial but just as usual uh when
they enjoying
when the engine is it is at its best so
yeah but when he started thinking I felt
like okay maybe he's going to play Queen
C3 and I wasn't quite sure if
it would be a blunder or it would be
like some uh sort of so you didn't feel
like this device preparation uh no I
mean he started thinking about like more
free when he saw like Bishop E7 he
started thinking yes sir clearly he was
uh
I think he expected some tarosh but uh
yeah I like but yeah
so then I'm not sure uh I'm not sure if
I uh did all right here should should be
all right for for white I believe are
out of like Common Sense yeah like two
Bishops in the pawn but
I guess somehow he was
[Music]
I think yeah he couldn't make up mind
like what what to do like play on or uh
Escape for a drill I'm not sure about
Bishop is six I think maybe bishop G4
makes some sense like enough to Bishop
uh I guess after Bishop C4
I can still play something like uh yeah
perhaps greenish 5 and 95 like I mean
there is like yeah some Bishop E2 yeah
so I think maybe bishop G4 was
695 is very safe for me and maybe if you
get some vicious I can also get some
better position because of game and my
Rooks on CNG yeah yeah so here I felt
like you can play Queen Bishop C4 or
maybe Queenie Queen E5 like uh should be
should be quite horrible yeah for white
again I guess I mean maybe unpleasant
but yeah it shouldn't be much worse but
yeah what she did was like very
ambitious but uh yeah I guess here I
mean if he's not losing by force it's
some sort of a miracle and maybe it's a
it's a miracle yeah I see no Evolution
totally so what's Black's plan why did
you assess it so aggressively for like I
mean my plan is just to deliver images I
have like chance of ideas like um G5
Knight H4 94 and H4 immediately Rook D2
a lot of different stuff yeah uh but
yeah and it's incredible like so in some
lines like Bishop Bishop B7 Rook B7
Queen D5 Bishop B7
uh take screen eight King H7 F3 Queen D2
and so on and so on and so on so I
collect B Trip on and I collect E3 pawn
and yes it's one of the first personal
video yeah I think yeah let's be greedy
but still it should be a draw yeah
because okay he plays in the energy
plays there's just rogi one and he he
holds
so it was uh yeah yeah I mean also where
there was a move like Queen uh I guess
Queen D7 uh instead of uh here yeah and
he plays Queen B6 and Rooks one would be
winning but there's Queen d8 otherwise
white is lost but okay this is winning
for white probably
uh so I played for some I don't know for
some took twang
uh yeah with Rook C4 so actually the
trick was like after Queen B3 I would
play I would play Rook D7
suddenly
uh what's my plan but uh yeah there was
like Queenie to move there also was like
the monkey played like Queen A6
and here I felt like yeah it shouldn't
be something special for me
uh sorry they decided to to pass a
little like King G7 I mean okay in the
end I can always make a draw but I think
it's at this point he also had like six
minutes on his clock I think that's
quite quite usual for him difficult for
him yeah yeah
but at the same time it is a
disadvantage right yeah I guess after
after before he sort of sort of imported
a short and important idea like Queen if
Queen A4 Queen E4 so this would like
simplify his task uh by like quite a lot
uh but here
well yeah and there's no Queen E4 of
course yeah there's just a queen trap
yeah it's a different story I guess yeah
yeah so he I think I couldn't triple
Queen yeah I guess Queen A1 F6 uh King
H1
I decided just to double my Rooks I felt
like Queen Queen E7 and queen E8 should
be a draw so he can basically give out
the pawn on F2
and go for activity but when he played
Bishop G3 of course it was like yeah
yeah I think after Bishop Jeffrey it's
uh probably be unsavable
it's option I do five I'm not sure it
was I saw that as soon as he played
Bishop to G3 you immediately played
Knight to F5 coins free is such a gift
like uh basically I mean if he just has
few Champions to activate his pieces he
should be all right yeah but once he
can't get this to to Bishop what was the
reddish the better move at this point
for him I know like Queen Queen A8 maybe
throwing like something
ah also 95 are interesting
okay it says Queen E7 but okay I guess
it's like it may be difficult to play it
because I'm sort of uh insinuating yes
I'm
some attack but yeah I guess also my
king is exposed and I'm once he starts
checking I think he's quite quite all
right with the counter play and finally
Bishop player works brilliantly yeah
Bishop like places on yeah place on C6
defense on YouTube so yeah but uh yeah
once again he was in same trouble
and after this you felt like yeah
yeah here his wife I I don't know this
is probably just uh winning by by many
many ways in these positions yeah
shouldn't be good for it
very nice game Jan how do you feel about
the the start of the event and what is
the goal the objective in this
tournament uh I don't know get some
rating points probably increase not uh
increase my rating a little it's all uh
maybe fight for some for some high
places uh I'm about to start yesterday I
felt like so bad about my game because
um
I guess uh I guess he played opening
like you know like
former Soviets Master candidates some
some solid moves and then okay some ugly
position completely ugly and was sort of
Revelation for me that this whole planet
of King on D4 was was not the correct
one because at some point I think the
position is already
I mean on the edge of being technical
for white yeah because it's like um
I mean if there is some if there is a
maximum in the isolating uh it was it
yeah but um
I decided to calculate some lines and
then yeah I think I plundered something
and uh yeah
uh ended up like this position where
where basically black would also play on
but uh yeah he made the draw so it was
like quite
uh quite annoying but uh
yeah even that he was an integral part
of Team ding for the last month and he
knew about it and your team knew about
it did you guys do any sort of special
preparation against him yeah
not really not really
I mean clearly uh
I would say his task was not in uh
holding black pieces uh yeah like uh
holding uh openings with uh with a black
color because
uh I guess among uh elite players he's
I mean uh difficult you know as bad as
paid yeah basically he has like the
worst opening preparation yeah but uh on
the other hand he's very creative with
white so it was obvious that some
some murky lines with yhr
uh could be expected yeah great insights
thank you very much you still have a lot
of games left we'll let you go get some
rest and get some preparation going
thank you guys back to you Christian
thank you Napa the loneliest man in the
world look at it Richard he's sitting at
the board he's enjoying his position but
at the same time there's that real gut
fear that it's not enough he has a good
position he's a pawn up but he's you can
see him bearing down into the position
as he's like gosh yeah
did I let it slip we all have that
moments where we think you know like I
should be winning I should be winning
and uh I'll just make one comment I
really liked what Napa said oh my plan
is to deliver mate yes yes exactly chess
is easy Checkmate wins the game uh nippo
is one of those players because uh uh
the Twitter question was as a
personalities who do you like
and we jump on ding because we said oh
he's so humble Lisa's soft-spoken it's
so very very nice uh nepo is also one of
those passive aggressive oh I'm just
such an idiot I can't I shouldn't be
allowed to play chess like he's one of
the greatest players in the world that
he despises the fact that he makes one
bad move out of a hundred he's a
perfectionist right yeah and you know
like oh I shouldn't be playing chess I'm
so so weak I'm so bad
hey we all struggle but yeah that's a
very very typical uh of a chess player
personality this desire to be perfect
we're not I can relate to that you can
relate to that you put a lot of pressure
on yourself too absolutely really yeah
yeah you don't give yourself more than
anyone else has ever put yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah uh jump in for uh What uh
what is happening in the current
position
well I think the current position is
block is holding black is holding black
is holding even with the very powerful
engines the evaluation comes to you know
equal position at the very end still a
lot of work to do you have to play
precisely but there is I've been
spending some time trying to find find a
plan but it's not so easy to find the
clear plan where white can make progress
this idea of Bishop H3 E4 doesn't work
anymore because we always have the pawn
on a four hanging so let's take a look a
few other options maybe how why can try
to make progress here all right so he
just played the move King B3 and now
King E7 is played King is actually well
placed here once again if we play Bishop
page three to attack the pawn he will
play King he can play both moves but he
can start with King E6 and a move E4 is
always met as long as your king is far
away from uh F4 Pawn it's always met by
this move Bishop H6 and try to pick up
the pawn on F4 so we can't really play
that here so so if we try to play the
move C4 to try to make progress just
Bishop F6
okay
and now if we go King A4 trying to go to
B5 then as soon as the king is uh going
24 then Bishop comes to C3 now with the
idea to play Bishop B2 so King B5 right
and now King D6
the point is if you capture on B6 I can
take
the pawn on B4 and now Bishop C5 check
I'll pick up the E3 Pawn as well no
don't take on B6 take on F5 okay so
let's take on F5 right it's a better try
definitely I can start with for example
King
to C7 defending B6 and now getting ready
to play the move Bishop D2
wow and we're losing one of the pawns I
guess yeah it sure it sure feels that
way doesn't it
good let's say C5 Pawn pigs
Bishop D2 and now trying to pick up the
pawn only three if you're taking D4 then
I will just simply take on before and
you should be able to make a draw here
gotcha
looks right so he just played the move
C4 actually
so this is the current position after C4
and now white black should play
King E6 for example
and Bishop H3 and uh Bishop if let's say
Bishop
F6 E4
and now once we play Four we now weaken
this Square which is very important
Bishop goes to D4
okay Bishop takes F5 King
E7 now threatening to play Bishop E3
okay so we can A4 King A4 King B5 King
A4
Bishop E3 King B5 King B5 and again now
King D6
in order to play King C7 before taking
the pawn on F4
so Bishop G4 we can play yeah King C7
now FY F5 if we want to keep the pawn
sure
and now uh both Bishop D4 Bishop F4
looks like they're both holding here
which before attacking the pawn if you
play H3 just simply F6
and it's going to be very hard to make
progress for white here this you know
he'll you'll get a position with two
extra pounds but looks like it's just
gonna be a fortress
yeah same issue the pawns seem to be too
close to each other so we can't use our
King to go on the king side and Cape
opponent's king protecting our past Pawn
just looks like black can hold both
sides one of the things about this
position from Black's point of view
is his defense is rather easy everything
loses everything loses you have to play
it like this right
and then you draw yeah but you know I
mean you have to allow E4 Bishop H6 you
don't have a choice you have to play
these moves and uh so all the pressure
is on white yeah that's where where
Richard has uh to come up with something
creative can he do it as we await the
answer to that question
we have a tweet well let's take a look
this one is from are we there yet
funny name uh the question is what do
you guys think are some of the most
distracting things that have messed up
games or tournaments of yours in the
past ladies first I have to think about
it so maybe you should go first oh well
that's easy in my case uh
the number one thing I really despise
and you should not do this this is
really something you do not do you do
not stand up and just look you stand up
and you look at the board as if you're
giving a symbol or something like that
that's number one second you don't come
around the back of me and you stand over
my shoulder looking down don't distract
the players you have people who are
Walkers they go back and forth that's I
I can deal with that that's okay but the
people who stand up as if they're going
to give a Simon I don't like that one of
my favorite stories of people who try to
distract me I was playing in my first
U.S open yeah it was this young Young
Junior B player uh playing for gosh I
don't know a b prize and you know it was
uh one of the biggest tournaments ever
in the United States like 750 people wow
and to find my name on this pairing list
I had to go down to like board 300 right
again I'm a b player and I played a
gentleman
very nice elderly gentleman white hair
beautiful smile fantastic smile
and over the course of the game his
position got more and more intense and
the smile turned into a grimace
and towards time trouble he'd taken a
glass of water took his teeth out wow
and put it in the glass of water and I'm
looking at the game bar this glass of
his teeth that had been smiling at me
since the start of the position were
looking at me from the from the glass I
thought that was hilarious kind of
distracted that was that was one of my
favorites what about uvar what distracts
you definitely yes sir when uh opponent
is you know making some noises you know
especially noise level if I'm in a
tournament room I like it to be very
quiet I'm very sensitive to noise I can
hear even if like somebody is Whispering
so that's one thing another thing yeah
chairs another thing sometimes I've had
experience even Grandmaster they they uh
they offer you a draw actually when it's
your turn to move oh yeah that's true
that would be a very distracting
and that's something you really want to
avoid and you should offer a draw only
when you make the move immediately make
a draw off or don't don't wait 30
seconds or a minute then offer a draw so
those are the things that definitely
distract me during the game yeah the the
those uh noises and what you said Is
Right draw offers now you thought of
something yeah when I first moved to the
United States and played one of my first
open tournaments okay the rules were
quite different here than what I was
used to in Europe okay so the players
were allowed to listen to music in their
headphones during the game yeah I've
seen a lot of open tournaments the guys
got these big and a few times my
opponents didn't have noise canceling
headphones so you could hear their music
during my move so that was quite
distracting yes right right uh one other
thing and I really uh I yeah it gets
pretty bad is remember you're trying to
win the game you're not trying to kill
your opponent distract your opponent or
something like that I love and I still
do the cross pens I thought that they
were very silent you could just go like
this and you make your move and you can
close them some people and I won't
mention any names they have the clicker
pens
so they're waiting for you to move and
they're like
like would you stop doing what you're
doing oh am I distracting you you think
I have a question for both of you a lot
of players like to pick up the pieces
that have been exchanged and play with
them in their hand very bad habit don't
do it you don't like it I hate it bad
habit don't do it VAR
um no I don't do it that much I maybe
maybe have done it rarely but I know
like there's particularly like there we
see dude
right now so the number one guy in the
world uh who does the the peace movement
of course is Boris Boris scale fund yes
and I was with Boris in uh Dusseldorf in
February of this year he had come to
this competition because they had all of
these side events going on and he was
giving chest training so I was warning
all the spectators don't do this this is
very very bad habit the dude they had to
stop Grandmaster right behind you so
Boris had come on the show and I said
Boris uh explained to the people about
your your habit yes very bad habits as
far so that's the very first thing he
said made me as happy as I could be uh
there are bad habits that you should
stop right away just don't even go there
that's one of them why because I'm not
just distracting for your opponent you
yourself will end up finding yourself
distracted it's sort of like you know
you start to look for a piece to grab to
grab onto and maybe it won't be there
and that will annoy you unless you're a
pro-like for his girlfriend right you
will eventually drop those pieces
exactly Blanc yeah
and we have uh one more tweet but thank
you uh good question many distractions
this one is from Tyler what it can't be
our Tyler very long question uh we
always say
try and show up and accept variations
but an outlier nicknamed the worst
opening in chess about attack yes
continues by uh Nakamura and even
Carlson against high-level opponents yes
some say it's a meme and some say it's a
self-imposed challenge what are your
thoughts uh it's a way of shaming your
opponent right it's like beating you
even with this happening dude you know
we can't play a game where I take a rook
off the board and I give you Rook odds
because the computer won't allow that
that's online so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to play the bottom Cloud which
is this absolutely horrendous opening of
moving my king in the opening so I give
myself a severe disadvantage and then
I'm going to beat you from a severely uh
bad opening and I remember this was I
the first time I'll just bring a
position up on I was a kid and I laughed
and laughed white plays E4
black plays the move E5 white plays F4
the so-called King's Gambit
black takes the pawn and now probably
the worst move on the board was
championed not once but on a number of
occasions by the first world chess
champion Wilhelm steinits and he played
the move b2b3 oh wow probably the worst
move on the one of the worst moves on
the board and this move is so bad
because of course it invites Queen H4
check G3 loses on the spot it's not the
bong Cloud it was a predecessor of the
bomb Cloud King E2 and now the question
to you Naji
is what is the move B3 all about
if your king is on E2 what is White's
goal
yes yes
and steinus would go on to beat his
opponents on the white side of this
position which is horrifying it's a
terrible terrible position I think I
would quit chess if I lost that's what
the bomb cloud is all about how about
you bar have you ever deliberately
played an absolutely awful opening just
to send a message to your opponent like
you should quit chats not a band cloud
or anything like that but I I actually
used to play the first move before when
I was a kid the orangutan yes well
that's perfectly okay yeah and I had
some success with it I developed like a
little system that I would get this
position so I didn't have any advantages
or anything just the playable positions
sir I did win some games against pretty
strong players like 22 2300 level player
but also lost some big games I lost to
Ruslan Pono Mario in one of the world uh
youth championships without opening okay
the orangutan b2b4 yeah but the bomb
cloud is you know early King and I I
think foreign
yeah but for Hikaru who has this you
know marvelous chest following and he's
doing all of the streaming and he's just
having a lot of fun yeah but he knows
that he's being this right kind of uh
poking uh towards his opponent but thank
you for the question and again let's
just uh check in on uh Richie's Uh
current position he has played C4 which
is a Prelude uh judah's playing again
with the pawn the bad habits
bad habits die hard uh absolutely and I
remember the first time
a friend of mine Michael Spiegel from
the Pacific Northwest he said yes sir I
got really bad news for you I go really
what's the bad news it says Soviet Union
is created two enormous geniuses
where's they I said the silly Ivonne
Chuck and Boris girlfriend I go what's
so special about them just look at their
games they're Geniuses okay
so the first time I played the silly he
spent five hours looking at the ceiling
like he was always like
four hours into the game I started
looking at the ceiling like there must
be something going on up there so he's
got the whole macrocosmic world that he
was analyzing and then I played Boris
galfan and Boris was looking at e0 he
had his eyes cast down and he was like
flicking the pieces and he would be so
he's in the microcosm I see
Vasily is in the macrocosm and yeah
between the two of them they had all the
worlds covered and I said Michael you
got it right yeah yeah that's right he
was right
uh move Bishop F6 suddenly uh perked
everybody up that that that move did not
get the seal of approval of our what
happened
yeah it looks like an inaccuracy it
looks like an inaccuracy and now
actually Bishop B7 is very strong so
let's take a look uh at the following
line now okay should be seven this
should be seven yeah now threatening the
move Bishop CA to pick up the pawn again
we want to pick up this Pawn with the
when we have the pawn only three we
don't really want to play that so you
have to play either king d8 or King D7
one of this one
logic now we can play a bishop D5 is one
option King E7 King E7
and perhaps we can go for this move C5
here
oh
takes
C4 yeah probably B5 B5 yeah and now we
have this B6 this is one option now
evaluation is slowly increasing here and
um if you play
King D6 now we can actually have seven
yeah that drops F7 Pawn so I think the
problem is if you remember guys in some
of these lines we actually had a bishop
where we were playing the move F6 right
and then Bishop f8 remember we had that
defensive idea in the six Bishop but now
you don't have that because the bishop
is on F6 so I think this is the main
problem here and if you play Bishop G7
King C4 attacking the pawn on C5 and uh
Bishop B2 B6 now the threat is very
strong B7 and we're going to be able
actually to win this Pawn on F7
cleanly and then still have a chance to
pick up the F5 Pawn for example if King
D7 Bishop takes
F7
this is C1 Bishop C1 the line continues
still King D3
and after King C6 you lose the F5 Pawn
Yeah
Bishop E6 again it's it still looks like
it yeah two connected past pawns though
I'm gonna be able to go King F3 keep on
and now we have there is C4 here for
example
and I'm gonna go King F3 Bishop C2 E4
and E5 and I put my black king goes to
E6 or F6 okay but with the pawns on F4
and E5
the C Pawn is not even a distraction
I've got I've got that under control one
idea we have to keep in mind guys in
this in this end game if black can
sacrifice the bishop for the two pounds
and get the king in time to G7 we'll
have the wrong color Bishop so that
could be another very important idea for
this position exactly
so in that position we're just
discussing
the pawns on e4 and F4 black can just
wait and sacrifice the bishop once you
push E5 okay run with the King to G7
right I'm trying to catch up with you
just too fast so that's good it's good
uh I love it your enthusiasm is
contagious uh B5 what were we playing
Bishop DC D6 Bishop F7 yes go girl go I
was
moving my Bishop doing something go
ahead tell tell me how we got that
position again how far can you help us
out please yeah absolutely so uh we have
a bishop F7 yeah
and let's see here
on move 44 actually there's also King 8
possibility here just try to defend here
but that line we got was King E7 yeah C5
yeah BC B5 and we were looking at the
move King D6 right it's an abstract
Bishop takes up seven
uh uh Bishop takes F7
Bishop well or maybe we played King C4
or something
actually we played sorry instead of
candy six we played move 46 Bishop G7
okay Bishop G7 okay yeah and then King
C4 Bishop B2
okay so B5 Bishop G7 King C4 Bishop B2
right
and then it was somehow B6 B6
Bishop takes
Bishop C1
King King
bishop and we were getting here and you
were telling me
how you were going to do this right so
black king goes to E6 or F6 okay he put
Bishop on C2 at some point right
discussing the position so kinky six you
push E4 and I stand with Bishop on B2
and as soon as you push E5 I take much
so let's just do that for a second and
the whole point is that okay let's take
king of six right that you're waiting
for the move E5 so you're you're waiting
for this opportunity
uh even though I'm a bishop up I can't
promote my H Pawn because your king will
be stuck in it will will be happily in
the corner here though are you sure
you're going to be able to get that
let's say I for argument's sake which is
going to make some moves I get to play
King G4 F6 okay but now I want to be
able to
get my king in time I'm hoping I will
zook swung you uh Tom is all
enthusiastic Bishop A2 there yes sir
Bishop A2 is very strong oh apologies
yes of course it is uh Bishop A2 and
thump right
right so yeah is an option for sure
yeah these these uh protected without
the h-ponds this position would be a
draw actually but with the H bonds it's
it's not going to be able not gonna be
easy even even though it's the wrong
colored h-pond it's it's the fact that
there exists is what it's all about
there Okay so
uh suddenly
Richard is being presented with a a real
opportunity again this is the current
position
and it's based upon this idea of being
able to play uh the upon breakthrough
essentially C5 and B5 Bishop D7 King D7
Bishop D5 King E7 C5 and B5 and
but with accurate play it should still
be a draw right I think that was what
BART told us last time with accurate
play it was a draw when the bishop was
on G7 you got this opportunity of
playing F6 and Bishop but because he put
his Bishop on F6 it might be
he blew it that Bishop on F6 could be
the losing move
and by the way didn't he it wasn't that
a losing move while he was doing the
fidgeting and everything are you going
to blame the the bad habits of course of
course cure yourself guys I'm looking at
the king he ate idea in this position
that I have let's see um
just to see if maybe he can play it this
way in King E8 here instead of the king
E7 move okay but looks like white can
actually just play C5 here
and if you take back you know we've been
looking at this B5 idea all the time but
now just B takes C5
okay and uh the idea is try to bring the
king to B5 here and the bishop is still
really passive now on F6 so let's say
Bishop to d8 trying to activate the
bishop via A5 so now King B4 stopping it
yep and um King E7 okay
King B5 so let's say you play F6
and uh
King C6 trying to put the King on uh B7
and then play the move C5 so a C6 so
Bishop A5 B7 this is just domination 77
yeah and um
Bishop G2 to H3
yeah Bishop G2 we can play or also even
Bishop F7 but let's say Bishop G2 yes
yeah
Bishop G2
and
Bishop d8 Bishop H3
King E6
and push the pawn push the Pawn King D6
this has to be six and the question is
if this is winning this position yeah
this has to be
how is it because we can get that
position with the wrong color Bishop we
can get that actually
well after C7 I'll take it
so we might be getting that position yes
Wise Guy huh
nice
um
I'm tasered wait a minute so we get a
position where he's two pawns up and he
gets his fabulous King on B7 and I can't
run you out of moves
no
you must be winning that position that
you that you have in front of you it's
only 1.5 yeah this is just because
there's just no a really good plan this
is actually a very good defensive
mechanism here with the King on D6 and
the bishop on d8 and every time we try
to make progress
uh let's say no Bishop A5 E4 and I'm
just just gonna play this moves Bishop
A5 to Bishop D okay uh go ahead and put
the bishop on C2 Bishop G4 Bishop G4
right Bishop A5 only only move right
Bishop D1 Bishop D1 Bishop d a yeah
again Bishop to G uh Bishop to C2
Bishop and now I want to play F5 and E5
like I want to get the Breakthrough that
way so let's say we start with F5 okay
okay Bishop Dade again right I don't
know if I need H3 or not but if E5 is
the idea right to take with a pawn and
you have to take with the pawn and then
I want to go FS oh but I'm I'll be right
there with king oh the bishop has to be
on B3 I apologize okay so in this
position if my Bishop was on B3 then I
could play F6
seven
C7 I take an E3 I think black still
makes it just wow
wow you're right you're right yeah it's
a decoy a few moves on the board yeah we
have some moves now guys okay before uh
Bishop H3 was played okay he didn't go
for the bishop B7 idea so Bishop H3
and the bishop H3 okay so essentially
after the move C4 Bishop F6 he didn't go
for any of these Bishop B7 and Bishop D5
ideas Richard went for the most direct
pardon me apologies for my cough Bishop
H3 King E6
E4 on the board now a moment ago
our E4 move would always be answered by
Bishop H6 now he doesn't have that
and he's got to play Bishop D4 so Bishop
D4 we get to take the pawn with a check
all right
I think Blackpool black was able to get
the F4 Pawn in the next movers all right
with Bishop E3 okay let's see it because
it's going to be one of those
moments where I go King
84 to B5 guys very important to move
right now King E7 is the only move
because you don't want to put it on D6
because of the E5 tempo right right
makes sense this is very very important
move now King E7 if we go King A4 Bishop
E3 Bishop E3 King B5
to bring the king to C7 I think I think
we can have this position right I think
so
yeah you're right okay uh so if I go H3
then you go King C7 yes right yeah
wow
that is
just what I thought I had the game in
the
in the bag there it's deeply engraved in
me that
yes
deeply I've been proven wrong many times
in my own games so we had fortresses
yeah they don't work not against Magnus
they don't they don't work
the English will teach us
Bishop takes F5 check King E7 crucial
moment
and that tell me about the the the times
of the players in this moment uh right
at the moment Richard has 12 minutes on
the clock and Duda has 15 minutes so
they both have plenty of time for this
kind of they'll get their 30 second
bonus but they'll that's all the time
they'll get from now on yeah no more 30
minute increment that's what I meant
yeah but yeah this is a lot of time for
them in this position and like you said
earlier it's pretty easy for black to
play
except maybe right now you're right he
needs to make one precise move King E7
and after that
it's pretty clear how black should
defend right there was this one game I
had
um it was against a Romanian Grandmaster
I think his name was kotesku I'm not 100
sure but I have been asked and it was
like this moment of great happiness
what's your longest combination what's
your longest combination
and I said 29 moves wow right thank you
right I got my winner 29 moves like
that's ridiculous yeah like that's
ridiculous but the idea was it was a
bishops of opposite color where it was a
palm breakthrough and you could
calculate it actually very easily
because of you know like what we've seen
these Bond breakthroughs and it was like
29 moves and yeah you sacrificed upon
him and it was a breakthrough and then
another breakthrough so yeah but it
sounds really impressive I mean it still
is even right but it is opposite color
Bishop so it's easy to calculate some of
these variations at times but Bishop
takes F5 King E7 on the board bar not
yet not yet not yet yeah your longest
combination
the uh my longest combination
um I can't think of it exactly right now
but I had some uh games that maybe I
calculated maybe seven eight moves right
like I started with a sacrifice and then
it just had to go through the all the
variations right nice yours just I mean
and it can be simple positions I know
two moves three months
I'll go into a coughing fit I'm a pretty
intuitive player so a lot of times I
will start uh with a sacrifice and not
know exactly how it's good It's gotta be
good but I have the intuition that I
will figure it out as we go it's got to
be good yeah
and we have a tweet as we wait for uh
the question of King E7 Force move
coming up
he did play King G7 by the way he did
this one is from Patrick Daly on YouTube
the question is how would you alter the
plane slash tournament conditions to
desensitize draws or incentivize more
risky play
you know
I'm sorry I I know what the questioner
is trying to provoke you know like as if
there's some beautiful magical switch
that makes everybody play their inner
tall
you know to me chess is a perfect game
it's just it is a fantastically good
game and if you know players like nepo
and ding sit down and they play their a
game and they sacrifice and do
everything they can most of the games
are going to be drawn right all I'm
interested in is a game that has a great
deal of content uh that uh that they're
not just playing but you know
a well-rehearsed drawing variations and
I'm not seeing that I'm not seeing it in
this tournament I'm seeing that the
players are really trying to create
positions where there's Mutual risks
like we saw today
and uh nepo and you know again I I just
take it with a grain of salt that
there's going to be a lot of draws
because that's when the players are just
playing really really well and that
doesn't bother me again so long as
they're out there you know challenging
one another I'm a happy camper yeah
I have so many tournaments where I would
have seven draws in a row wow But to
answer the question I think the one way
to incentivize players so maybe play a
little bit more aggressively is a
different scoring system okay where we
have two points for a win 1.4 a draw and
zero for a loss okay that's but that's
right yeah it didn't that doesn't change
anything right did I do it wrong you you
wanted to perhaps suggest three points
for the win like the soccer like like
yes exactly and I think there's been a
number of tournaments where that has
happened and I believe that Magnus
Carlson actually won one of those
tournaments where he was way behind but
thanks to an incredible streak at the
end where he won let's say three in a
row he got nine points and he ended up
tying or winning first
um one of the things that I I really
salute Norway chess on this one was they
had this idea that the players made a
draw then they would immediately play an
Armageddon game
and then you get this you know half
point of one extra for the Armageddon
and the idea was you know like you know
you want to see a win right or from each
uh no that's interesting but that's very
hard on the players but wonderful for
The Spectators absolutely how about you
VAR Jump Right In uh do the players need
more incentive I love brilliancy prizes
by the way I think that's nice but sorry
I I interrupted you no absolutely I
think the way it is right now it's fine
I know there were some other tournaments
previously they used the soccer system
with three three points for the win and
one for a draw and uh but I think uh
with with extra prizes we have the
brilliant surprise in some of the
tournaments I think it's gonna motivate
the players and what we have here in
grantchester no draw offers that's gonna
resolve that thing also in more decisive
games and more complete games and we're
not gonna see those short 15 20 Move
games too often I think at the moment
it's fine and players already really
motivated I mean the price fund for
example for this tournament is so big so
they need to win games right to win the
tournament so I think there is already a
good motivation for them to try their
best to win absolutely as we prepare
ourselves for a break we just remind
everybody of our results thus far on
this round two right we had a first four
draw between by Sheila grave and Wesley
so Wesley very happy he came into today
with one point yeah so a draw Cambria
was happy too because he was unhappy
with the opening true and then we have
giriferuja draw and one win in this
round by nipom Nishi against dick and
Dean caruana pretty quick draw right and
one game remaining Richard's uh and Pole
Position Kenny pull it off we'll find
out on the other side of the break
foreign
[Music]
chess tour is back for its eighth trip
around the world inspired by former
world champion Gary Kasparov the
grantchester hosts the top players to
compete for top prizes eight of the
world's best joint tournament wild cards
and travel to four different countries
to fight for a 1.4 million dollar prize
fund the tour kicks off in Bucharest
Romania for the superbet chess classic
then things speed up as we move to
Warsaw Poland and Zagreb Croatia for the
first two rapid and Blitz events the
tour then makes its way to St Louis
Missouri for the final two events we're
back in November for the St Louis rapid
and Blitz and the illustrious sinkfield
cup when points are up for grabs the
best players show up who will be crowned
the new Champion find out when the grand
chess tour returns
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of round two of our
Bucharest Romania as we see we only have
one game remaining as three games have
been drawn one game was a win for nepo
as he is currently tied uh with Wesley
so and we think that Richard is going to
join them in a tie as he is enjoying a
winning advantage against Duda bring up
the game position where as we were going
on break we were saying to ourselves
King E7 was the only move to draw the
game should he have found King E7
remarkably enough we think the game
would have been drawn
he did play King D6 and immediately the
table base was able to show us that this
position is actually winning thanks to
the move Bishop G4 that's the only
winning move by the way and after the
move H3 if white is allowed to play H3
F5
King here King here it's a very very
easy win after H3 what this move does is
it forces a trade of one more pawn
bishop takes H3
Bishop down to G1 after King A4 Bishop
takes H2 F5 we immediately go into a
table base and remarkably enough the
table base tells us with complete
absolute certainty that C5 B takes C5 B
takes C5 is winning
it's a little bit surprised
for you and Harry both I always thought
you needed three squares yeah files yeah
three rows between so so you and I would
immediately say oh no well if the pawn
were on G5 this is absolutely uh a
winning position uh and this is another
way of doing it is maybe with the King
uh far enough farther the better right
in principle yes and I and I think I
could have done it that would have
forced you to
capture with the pawn right somehow uh
but in any case VAR you were the one
that pointed it out uh table basis I'm
not going to argue with the table base
absolutely yes they're actually in this
position that we have on the screen
right now there is even a move F6 here
that white can play it looks like that
movie is also winning we can look at
some of the lines now and if we place
here F6
and the idea is to uh put the pawn on F7
so Bishop rest to E5
F7 trying to promote and very important
that if you play King E7 try to win the
pawn there is the smoke Bishop E6 clear
and um
so this is one option so let's say you
play the move Bishop G7 you try to
defend this way now King will go to A4
King C7
now King B5 Bishop f8
and now looks like we can move the
bishop to D5 or even just go immediately
for the C5 right takes
Pawn takes C5
and again your table base is popping up
and I can see Bishop G7 now King C4
and the king is eventually going to go
to G8 here so Bishop f8
King D5 and by the way Richard has
played F6 yeah Bishop E7
Bishop G2
Bishop fed and now we have C6
and we again we're going to maneuver the
king all the way to
uh H7 here yeah
and there is no good way to defend both
pawns because there is there is split up
the exact way that we need it here to be
able to
uh yeah and now here just King H7 yeah
and uh looks like uh yeah and
we recognize the inevitability of what
you were showing the white king will
come to G8 cos black as bishop and Duda
is going to leave playing Hall in deep
disgust and I'm with him 100 because
there was no way what he was losing this
game he just kind of took his eye off
the ball played that just relaxed
the Rooks and once he saw Bishop takes
D1 and B4 uh it was bad news it was two
very very bad news
um remarkably that leaves us with three
players tied for first yeah first win
for white in this tournament and the
first win for white wow okay uh
excellent as Richard Rapport Wesley so
and Ian are all tied uh with one and a
half out of two as I guess we're getting
ready to have Richard uh in the
meanwhile uh lay the table for
tomorrow's parents um take a look who's
playing tomorrow we have Fabiano caruana
against Mexico
wow nice and
what to say about this one he promised
against ding they haven't played each
other enough recently no they have not
exactly then we have Duda against
diaca against Robert right wasn't so
against anishkiri very nice yeah and I
wouldn't want to be a diox position
right now because Duda is like he's
throwny throwing lightning bolts and uh
you know he's saying okay I have to
recover tomorrow exactly exactly yeah as
we get uh I I hope we get a chance to
interview Richard Richard is always good
for he's always a good interview by the
way there was a question that this
tweeted as what is also distractions and
there was one uh what um pardon me uh
Sami rashevsky was the worst He Loved
These really hard rock candies so they
were always wrapped in these really
tight Plastics they make as much noise
as possible he popped him in his mouth
and he'd do one of these
hmm oh my God I mean the tournament Hall
would empty because this that's worse
than chewing gum exactly it's it's
terrible eating at the board no no yes
uh eating at the board so those were
more distractions that we forgot to
mention
and far uh this game I mean even though
Duda blew it
he had more chances to save the game he
was like he kept offering the point
absolutely yes it's probably the the
most unpleasant way to lose a game if
you make a blunder at least you know you
made a really bad move and you lost the
game but here he he played this B5 move
and put himself in a real big trouble
and then he got back into the game after
Richard allowed him with the king2 move
and where he almost hit a draw here just
had to find the move King E7 he made
that blunder with King D6 allowing E5 E5
check and E6 and giving Richard the
victory very unpleasant you guys are
doing terrible
yeah
nobody I mean three players tied for
first and not one of us got any it's a
long turn it's a long tournament we
still like uh where we stand
as round two goes into the history books
right we have three co-leaders Wesley
saw Fabiano caruana and Jani from the
shoe with one and a half points world
champion dingler in in the chasing pack
right along with an ishqiri Maxim
Rachelle Graham and Richard rapid with
one point actually Robert has one in
half yeah
our graphic artists really must like
Fabi did she uh did Megan pick Fabby uh
you know like you know he kind of
promoted Richard got demoted in that
graphic but it's actually written you're
right uh oh I say right so Fabiano and
Richard right yes switched okay but for
a moment there I was going with the flow
that looked pretty good that looked
pretty good I believe myself when I read
it exactly exactly we're trained that
thing
and as we get uh Richard wired up one of
the things I'm noticing VAR again you're
doing a lot of theory these days opening
theory is the players have really mixed
up their openings and I've got got to
say I love that it's not like
everybody's in lockstep fashion with one
another absolutely yeah you can just
play the same openings over and over
like maybe 15 20 years ago you have to
mix it up you have to play D4 sometimes
C4 start out with Knight F3 you really
have to be unpredictable to make it a
lot harder for the other players to
prepare against you to spend more time
instead of prepping for one or two hours
they spend maybe three hours so that's
why having a more broad opening
repertoire is very important these days
exactly and uh Fabi with his Knight A5
but let me interrupt myself and say uh
let's jump to Bucharest Christian we're
the winner
Richie I thought this game is going to
be over uh two three hours ago what just
happened yeah I kind of shared your
ideas and enthusiasm also about the game
finishing very quickly no I yeah I don't
know in the opening I kind of forgot to
play for I think I played this at one
point I guess Fiddler um yeah he's
surprising with this idea and I this
have a night before game against
swindler yeah I guess Peter and a
singfield cup
some years ago and I think I played A4
at some point but I couldn't recall it
instantly or necessary
and yeah it was the same thing actually
um but then he went
somehow Knight F6 and queen D7 after
Queen D3 so 36. yeah I think this is
maybe a bit better for white I had a
feeling but obviously if or if I've
included it I would have been
a better structure if it would help your
cause you have some Bishop to maybe
attack the uh yeah like after when I
play um B3 C4 like in the in the
extremely Far Far Future the structure
is just simply more present so I thought
you know I went for this
cute idea with Knight F4 I was quite
happy about this but then um right away
after H6 I I kind of missed I think I
should have just captured F6 and queen
B3 maybe some slight pressure with this
opposite colored Bishops playing for C4
deck in a decade or something yeah and
then Queen E7 was played and um
here yeah my original idea was to take
on F6
obviously but here once whatever reason
uh yeah that's that's an impossible move
to make
we cannot make moves there we go okay
yeah
three and um Bishop G7 King G7 ba3 and
you know the problem is yeah whatever
the point is that the Knight is arriving
and I'm not on time to to create
anything and then I decided okay I will
at least have a rest day
um yeah and that's what we thought as
well we thought that we're going to
interview uh you uh two hours ago after
a draw yeah exactly and then it was very
I mean he missed um he was he got
careless obviously because he fought
everything he's a joke I mean you know
the good news is that um he has this
double pawns so
um and maybe 1 B3 is quite amazing so
like I'm not at risk at all and he
wanted to you know probably wrap the
game up very quickly with yeah A4 B5
idea and he missed obviously uh Bishop
takes D1
um I mean when you saw P5 did you
understand that you're starting to get
some chances yeah I mean I saw this as
like my kind of last trick uh obviously
I don't know if I guess maybe still a
draw I mean I don't think I don't know
if it's a winning provide or not yeah
but it was quite clear to me that he he
wanted to stop the Rooks and play before
and and liquid it yeah and that was
quite um okay I'm not saying I was quite
proud but you know like Bishop takes D1
is a nice move to make and obviously he
kind of missed it based on his speed of
you know playing B5 quite quickly and
before and yeah this end game I thought
maybe he should have gone for a four
here but I'm not so sure if uh I think
this was the computer so yeah this is a
draw or this is lost already but like
take and G5 right it felt like yeah
first it felt like a better um
but you know this is super desperate
um I mean this this kind of effort yeah
and um it could be just that he is just
losing so obviously it's very hard
psychological dude this type of
situations ever happened to you and what
are those emotions when you realize okay
I'm not finishing the game anytime soon
I'm actually going to be tortured for
the next two three hours yeah sometimes
it was on the receiving end of things
sometimes I was you know like today
um beneficiary of these these changes
it's not a lot of good feeling to have
obviously if you're um you know in
trouble yeah but at the end of the day
this is uh this is the game and if you
know I I learned them
something from a you know my recent
experience and with the guys on the
highest level that the game is basically
um somehow never over here until it's
over so you have to be you have to be
careful yeah
it's not not a you know not my proudest
moment obviously to win this game even
afterwards obviously it's a great deal
but you know yeah sometimes it happens
sometimes you get lucky yeah this way so
I obviously take the win I don't know if
I missed something from knowing myself
it's very like I think at some point
maybe you let him back in the game but
yeah it could have been yeah I I didn't
it's very unclear the engine yeah you
can see for him but at some point he
came up with this very clear this was
the moment so after Bishop to H3 King is
six and then we Shuffle the pieces a bit
oops excuse me
and you played this move
King to E6 Bishop to F1
and then after you grab the second pawn
bishop to D4 take on F5 and now King to
E7 instead
actually I wasn't sure I thought it's
really in King A4 King A4 King d8 and
now King yes the same same idea not
Bishop before I thought this is just to
me I mean and then A5
and if H3 I have E5 Bishop f4h3 my
Bishop goes to fh5 I provoke F6 C5 and
then King G4 E5 I break here I felt like
it's kind of a reasonable sequence and
perhaps this is what he was worried
about as well yeah his opponent H4
sometimes there are these issues here
like just put the bishop to D5 Pawn to
C5 and then King to G4 yeah C6 actually
doesn't matter if I didn't see at least
maybe maybe I'm missing something but uh
yeah it felt like
yeah like I said it could be that I'm
missing something you know it could be
that his King is fast I don't know yeah
uh even so he was falling down on time
as well he was having huge problems with
his time at this point a lot of pressure
and uh you were able to take the full
point home this is an encouraging sign
for you and an encouraging start to the
tournament as well how are you feeling
right now not really encouraging you
know I mean the game should have
anything 20 moves bro but yeah certainly
a nice feeling to to start with a
certain plus one you know let's say
um
I mean I cleared it on the zero plus one
out of these two games but you know
sometimes things happen that you don't
deserve one way or another so you take
it this is life yes congratulations
Richie we'll see you tomorrow
Christian thank you Richard another
self-deprecating uh Richie it's not
surprising that dingler and Richie
somehow found one another in our world
uh VAR uh makes some summations we're
going to ask Christian to do the same
we're going to call it the broadcast
what did you think of this round suit
another very exciting ground uh Yasser
we have two decisive games the Richer
reports win came out of nowhere we were
expecting this to be a drop but Jan
showed that he's ready to fight and
winning with a black PC against deck you
know proved that he's in good shape I
think he can do really really well in
this Advanced overall a great great day
I think now it's a three-way tie for the
first place so I'm excited and looking
forward to the remaining rounds in this
tournament and back to a Christian in
Romania
yeah well I couldn't agree with you more
as we get ready for round three but let
me throw it to Christian in uh Romania
and Christian your take on round two
foreign
yeah it was just another exciting day of
Chess here in Bucharest Romania I did
not anticipate as many decisive results
I was understanding that nepo is getting
quite significant chances at least
practical chances forget about the
objective evaluation of the engine
saying that is zero zero zero it wasn't
like that because that was falling
behind on the clock and definitely nepo
was uh increasing the pressure in the
position I felt like he could get a full
Victory but I have to say uh Richie
getting a victory in that game was just
an incredible feature in uh this round
and I'm looking forward to see what
these players are going to bring to the
chessboard tomorrow very exciting
tournaments of archives wonderful
wonderful thank you Christian we look
forward to tomorrow's round once again
as we close our broadcast these are the
standings right we have two exciting
games and these are the correct
standings right the co-leaders are
Wesley so Richard rapper
with one and a half out of two world
champion ding Loren only two draws right
and then we have few players with one
point anishikiri and viel and Fabiano
Carolina right and do that Daniel and
Ali Reza are with half a point because
we've got three people in one point
three people with not so many points
wonderful and it was our it was our
pleasure uh to be broadcasting thank you
so much for joining us tell your friends
where you're hanging out get ready with
your questions for tomorrow and we'll
see you all tomorrow well done all right
you're doing great thank you all good
see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited